insecurity and a lack of confidence
probably causes 90% of the problems on
this planet there are people who let
life happen to them and then there are
people who like create their life I just
see them accept defeat far too easy
there is 50 different ways to get what
you just asked for you just literally
just gave up I have never been concerned
about money I've always always felt like
I'll be successful so I've just always
spent like I've had it what's the point
of having money if you're not going to
play First Class what's your advice to
someone who's thinking about buying a
house right
now I appreciate you guys com on so I'm
curious to start this off what is one
thing that you would critique about the
other and one thing that you guys yeah
hold on a second can we just say that
warm this is crazy you guys haven't done
a podcast together I don't think also I
can't one thing can I do like a top 10
for sure yeah if there's too many just
the biggest issues how long two hours
start is that enough time okay you want
me to go alphabetical numerical I think
it's funny cuz Graham says you guys have
some of the funniest ban you guys love
to argue love to debate and apparently
you guys are like philosophically a
little bit different right like pretty
close you say you'd say very in
alignment or is it yeah I'd say very in
alignment okay we we argue and debate
over like Nuance like just micro nuances
okay well we want to find that Nuance in
this that's what we're looking for get
last piece of pizza that's what about
yeah it's not like philosophical debates
or politics it's Pizza like whose foot
whose favorite football team has the
best like receiving Trio that's it yeah
that's dumb what's one critique you guys
have for each other I'll let you go
first so I can see how like how deep
going exactly deep the cut is exactly um
and I want him to know there's something
hanging over his head when he's talking
right now I'll go after you he repeats
himself when we
argue that's annoying I I can get behind
that I I haven't seen that from you but
when people start being redundant in an
argument it's like I understand you know
what makes people redundant is when the
other party has absolutely like no Focus
or care or like m you know [__]
around with their phone and they just
they're not listening you know that's
what makes people repeat themselves
right so you redundant for a purpose
yeah exact out of
necessity okay so these issues are
aligned that's fair yeah do you think
he's redundant or no probably not as
much as I am okay yeah he's never
admitted that he's probably just more
like you know he he'll keep the debate
SL argument going more than I'll be like
I'm good and then he'll keep but I think
he's probably less respectful in the
manners in which he I don't know relates
to to people generally cuz he's just I'm
busier is what he's
saying it's called busy you know it's
like bro did you hear what I said it's
called a work ethic bro did you hear
what I said and he's like stop repeating
yourself like dude you haven't looked up
your phone in eight
minutes it's funny because i' I've
worked with you guys for a long time and
I see both perspectives on this I think
you're mostly on your phone or doing
emails or like talking to someone else
while Brett's talking even if it's
Instagram can I cuss on this part yeah
yeah go ahead even if it's Instagram
you'll be like in the middle of it like
dude you're like swiping left I know
you're not working right now on the way
here he was driving I was on a work call
for 15 minutes he gets so [__]
annoyed so usually I just have to take
my own Uber cuz he gets so annoyed
that's that's insane that you take your
own Uber dude but imagine picking
somebody I'll come pick you up you know
cuz you're kind of on the way whatever I
got the music on like breeze in my hair
I'm like cool morning I'm hung over his
hair chill yeah we I'm chilling I'm in
like perfect you know okay like the
podcast coming I'm I'm like just going
to relax on the way there oh oh I got a
call with a veler in in Canada I'm like
dude you just could have taken an Uber
then I mean I got to listen to this
[__] the whole way here that's a
good I got to turn the music down I got
to put the window up now you have to
accommodate pisses me up that's true
yeah Point Let's see one thing that you
admire in the other person oh also tons
of things I admire feel like this is
like marriage counsel yeah I I want to
work through this Grandma was just
telling me how funny it is when you guys
start there tons of things that we
admire you know we actually went to like
a a couple's therapist well not a couple
therapist well I think she's trained as
a couple's therapist or maybe not I
don't know why did but we went for like
just to get along better yeah was there
something that happened no we just were
fighting a lot when was remember when we
were years ago yeah yeah we're better
now do you remember like 5 10 years ago
it would fight way more oh it was like
ridiculous we would get in fist fights
in in the at lunch in the just told me a
story about that yeah yeah we don't
physically fight as much anymore no cuz
he's like just more intimidated now for
good reason Jack was wondering do you
guys have a lot of aggression that just
like you just have
it's only Brett just naturally in our
character I feel like we have a lot of
you know yeah we're both Alphas so you
get us together and we just fight over
[__] but we're not as yeah we're not as
we don't have the physical
confrontations way but you used toys
fight we did fight we had to separate
ourselves in high school like different
high schools we to separate ourselves
like a week ago when we were in that
Uber in yeah that's true we still we
still go but it's rare like once every
few months we'll fight I had to jump out
of an Uber in Nashville cuz I was
literally like we were about to going
blows yeah and I I'll meet you at the
stadium how many times do you guys think
I would love to see one of these fights
you guys could be a main card in like a
some sort of box I told I told it would
be so even like yeah I think that would
be a little bit you think so I'd get him
you usually more cuz he bites
I I don't I have more aggression so I
think I I would yeah that's probably
true he used to like kind of beat me up
a I'll pin him I'd pin him down but
that's crazy you guys end up going to
blows because I have a brother not
really like punching in the face more
like rest L and like you know chill cold
and like maybe punching in the CH we try
to avoid El like we try not to actually
just boom although I knocked him out
cold a couple times did you yeah dude I
did let's let's I want to expl like
laying on the ground it's like
motionless so how does it go from like
just something you're disagreeing upon
to like actually fighting your T brother
like where does the escalation happen
more and more irritation just stupidity
and then one person will like you know
push the other person or whatever and
then it just happens and and you like
fighting I'm guessing because it
continues to happen no I just we can
irritate each other sometimes no nobody
likes I mean really like fighting you
know if I get irritated or if Graham
gets irritated it's not like it is never
within my frame of mind of like okay
same with everyone else on the plan
here's the thing if you and Graham
fought it would be a big deal and you
could you could maybe not have the Pod
for weeks who knows if you even come
back to like being friends we can fight
in like 30 minutes like we did in in
Nashville like you know we're 20 minutes
later we meet up maybe it took 15
minutes after seeing each other like
relax but and later we fine yeah so you
guys know no matter what yeah I think
that's part of it too you just take you
take for granted you take for granted
the relationship and so you fight cuz
you know that it's not going to damage
the relationship that's really that's
really different that's very unique
Graham was telling me you guys were like
at a getting lunch at some spot and then
like across the table from each other
you started like bickering and bantering
forget what it was about yeah too just
about something probably trivial as I'm
guessing like a lot of these things it's
never about anything of substance and
then you were just like all right let's
go outside and you guys just went into
the back parking lot and we didn't see
you and I I think I was with Mary and
all of them are say oh you just leave
them be they do this they do that like
should we be worried no no no they'll
come back and I think one of you yeah
one of you left and then I think it was
you Jason I think you just sat down like
nothing had
happened that tracks tracks yeah so how
do you think having a twin is different
from having a normal sibling uh you're
just closer yeah I don't think there's a
closer relationship on the planet if you
work towards it than identical twins and
what is that like have somebody that
always keeps you in check when do you
give him authority to make decisions on
your behalf well it's I wouldn't put it
that way I generally don't make
important decisions without like us
agreeing Consulting and does it have to
be like a unilateral decision no no but
I take his advice seriously so bilateral
you mean um like like like Mutual like
bilateral is that how it is I think
unilateral will be one person are you a
lawyer too um yeah that yeah that makes
a lot of sense yeah yeah yeah it's an
adviser you know that you go to I I
trust his opinion as much as mine so
it's hard for me to make an important
decision like let's say I'm going to
open up a new office somewhere I I kind
of have to get Brett on board um so that
I'm confident in it you know if he has
reservations then I rethink my decision
but how do you guys build that level of
respect and Trust for each other like
that 46 years of of just like seeing the
person making good decisions and like
earning and admiring the other person
imagine if you guys had this podcast for
46 years
would you would you he might actually
listen to me
then it's different because you guys
have had a very similar if not the same
upbringing yeah so I think going through
that and being related ties that even
closer than Jack and I but I'm just
trying to give some perspective would
you wor would you worry about what
guests he's going to bring on or what
questions he'd ask or whether he can
after 46 years of this no you know
you've seen everything 10 times that's a
good point yeah I what okay so did you
guys actually have you had to be in
different high schools yeah yeah my
McDonald's is here I I don't want to
continue bringing this back to the
fighting but for me my McDonald's is
here oh yeah yeah sure sure thanks Budd
so I I can't believe that you guys had
to be separated intentionally because of
the the fighting all through most of
through high school when did that start
at what age did you guys start most of
our fighting was probably four five
probably start 14 was our wor was there
ever genuine like hatred you think but
it was mostly trivial it was never
anything but it was always trivial we
never did anything but love each other
more than anyone else on the planet
that's the fighting isn't about you know
like I don't like you as a person it's
just I
want yeah I think you know raise like
basically by our mom and when we saw our
dad you have a brother I have an older
brother yeah you guys fought now but I
was I mean he he was two and a half
years older than me so there was a bit
of a size difference for most of the
time we were growing up so I would be
like the provoker I would annoy him and
then he would fight and it's like I
can't do anything you know he's way
bigger than okay so you could imagine
though if you guys were like pretty
tight the exact same size things could
have been different yeah yeah how about
Graham uh half sister but how much of
that fighting do you think is because
you put on the ground don't take up the
ho
no yeah
exactly like wow this big for $4.99 is
such a great deal huh
Graham uh how much of the fighting
though do you think is because you were
Twins and very competitive with each
other and proving that like hey I I have
a oneup like I'm the better twin no zero
yeah okay it was literally just two
Alphas in a
room you know
do like what's going to happen this
Alpha stuff because that's kind of been
like blowing up recently with like the
alpha mindset Alpha mentality oh yeah
why do you say that you're an alpha how
how do you determine if you're I mean I
could technically be using that term
wrong but I'm pretty sure you know just
kind of a naturally aggressive kind of
if you're in a room with a bunch of
people you're or you know your boys
you're probably going to be the guy
making the decisions you're probably
going to be kind of like you know one of
the bigger presence in the room just not
not on purpose it's just your
personality you know and was someone
else like that and you and you kind of
want to get your way and you kind of
just have like that a large presence in
your personality but first if you're in
business just like us I'm sure you're
well aware that problems are everywhere
for example there was actually a
scheduling issue that made it so Graham
couldn't be in the studio to record this
with me sorry Jack and there Comes A
Time in every business when the problem
that you've been ignoring needs to be
handled Graham I said I'm sorry Jack if
you're getting frustrated with how
you've been selling whether that be
online or in person I could not
recommend you guys try out our sponsor
Shopify enough Shopify is the e-commerce
platform that's already helped transform
millions of businesses worldwide for
example you can customize your online
store with flexible templates and
Powerful tools and with a single
dashboard you can manage orders shipping
and payments from anywhere in the world
here's a fun fact what sets Shopify
apart from its competitors is its
ability to turn browsers into buyers
with the internet's best converting
checkout that's 36% better on average
compared to other leading e-commerce
platforms and Shopify actually Powers
10% of all e-commerce in the United
States supporting Brands like Alberts
rooies and Brooklyn in over 175
countries in fact my coffee company
bankroll coffee run exclusively through
Shopify and I did a ton of research on
the best e-commerce platform to use and
they've been fantastic plus they have an
incredible support team there to guide
you every step of the way I can attest
to this so sign up for a $1 per month
trial period at shopify.com
again that's shopify.com
take your business to the next level
shopify.com thank you so much Shopify
and back to the podcast this is
something I want to I want to understand
on a deeper level because something that
Graham I feel like learned a lot from
the both of you is this kind of like
Alpha presence Alpha mentality and now
I'm not saying gra Gram's I would never
admit to such a thing but a lot of the
times when I go to advice for Graham he
is kind of just like a relay for your
advice that you guys haveed on every
single time he's like well I remember
having this talk about you know this or
whatever about with Brett or Jason or
something and he just relays it and it's
always the same kind of like stoic no
nonresponsive uh non-responsiveness to
certain things and like being precise
and like this Alpha mindset and I'd say
we don't take no for an answer which is
probably somewhat Alpha but our dad had
like a motto of whatever it takes and I
think we have that instilled in us like
we just get what we want by working for
yeah you kind of have in the back of
your mind like this is going to happen
just a matter of how difficult it is and
that's the the mindset from which you
operate but I don't think I do that on
purpose that's kind of just in my blood
I'm glad I'm able to impart some of that
you think you got that from or do you
think you were kind of raised in that
both my parents are kind of alpha I
would say but um yeah that's something
my bones like I don't I never write a
book on how to be alpha or anything or
watch videos I just was that we were
that way from four years old and it's
not like necessarily something that
we're bragging about when I say Alpha
I'm just using it as a purely
descriptive term I'm not sure it's
advant it's probably advantageous in
life in some ways and disadvantageous in
others so I'm not like telling everybody
be Alpha necessarily in what ways would
it be bad well you people the wrong way
we also I think get frustrated at um
things that that we think can be done
better so you can you can get irritated
and frustrated at other things because
you just want to take over and do it MH
so it's kind of hard to delegate it's
kind of hard to uh for people to live up
to your expectations if you're not in
control of something it bothers you I
could see it shouldn't probably the
alpha personality for lack of a better
term we're just assuming we we'll assign
that word to this thing we're describing
could be could make it challenging to
get very close to certain people I feel
like it it it makes you pe people seem a
little bit more distant we have very
close relationship with friends and
family we probably okay but to to enter
through to break through to that to be a
part of the close Circle would you say
it's more challenging because yeah could
those people lead because you would need
to be the one in charge because I've
noticed even hanging around you you're
usually the one that says oh we're going
to go to this place tonight and oh we
have this connection over here let's go
there and everyone else that's with you
is like yeah that's that's great and you
don't really find lot of conflict no I
don't want to go there to hard for alas
to be together just like in the wild
that's why Brett I fight because we're
you know we we you disagree on mean you
can learn about Alpha Behavior by
watching National Geographic you don't
have to interview US I mean we're just
animals humans are just animals and we
act in very similar ways to two alpha
Lions hanging out in the in the wild
they're not going to do very well
together they're going to have to have
their own Prides and when they come
together there's probably going to be
some scuffles and they could be brothers
but it's not that much different than
like Alpha and anim in the wild that's
where the term came from I you think it
could be learned I don't know if it
you'd want it to be learned I think yes
I think we learn I think we learned it
too I think it's nature and nurture
absolutely yeah we're I think there's
part of being Alpha that's probably
beneficial in life and I maybe would
impart for some people to try to learn
that which is achieving your goals I
want to say no matter what cost because
that seems a bit extreme but have it in
the back of your mind a lot of people
like I'm when I'm talking to some people
in the office or just some people in
life I just see them accept defeat far
too easy it absurdly easily and I'm just
like what there is 50 different ways to
get what you just asked for you just
literally just gave up so I would impart
that you know get it in your mind this
is going to happen and then and then
when you get that in your mind and you
effectuate it with that mindset then the
next time you're oh [__] I really can't
make that happen like you know sometimes
you're in a traffic jam like usually
especially in like second and third
world countries and there's some people
just sit in the line like forever and
someone opens a door gets out and starts
directing traffic that's us like we'll
get out make this guy go in here make
this guy pull over here and get this
going like I'm not going to sit here for
an hour there's no effing way I'm
sitting where did you learn that
behavior though cuz I feel like there's
got to be something where you've seen it
and then started modeling that as you I
mean I'd say well both of our parents
but I'd say our dad particularly has I
don't do you think it was learned do you
think if we were raised a different
parents I think I still feel like we'd
be this way well I don't think we'd be
as much cuz I think they instilled a lot
of confidence in us and like made us
believe that we could you know succeed
at what we do and then also we saw them
you know very persistent I mean our dad
would not be someone that would take no
I think that's totally fair but I think
it's a mix cuz I also feel like it's in
my bones you know and you'd have to like
beat it out of me no matter who raised
me but it's probably accentuated by my
parents at what age did you start living
with your dad my understanding he took
over when you guys were not doing so
well in school and put you on a
different path I got expelled when I was
a sophomore in high school what did you
do oh just dumb [__] we got sent to
boarding schools and then I got exp well
we both got expelled so my dad took me
in um after the sophore 15 or 16 and
then Brett got expelled like six months
after me what did you do oh I mean it
was likeu weed and fighting and nothing
crazy but you know when you when you had
a board in school they're not super
tolerant I was never good with authority
neither of us were good with authority
from day one yeah um yeah so our
childhoods were you know I don't think
Alphas are good with authority yeah
that's another issue with being Al so
how did your dad handle that my dad's
also not good with authority when my dad
took us it was like well this is
actually ironically like if you need to
I we're this is devolving into like just
a full Alpha conversation but if you
need to control an alpha it has to be
full basic just structure and dominance
it's the only way to keep an alpha in
check so my dad literally took over our
Liv like that's that's why the Marines
is probably good for Alphas you know
because they don't have a choice you
have to put them in such a structured
environment that they have no choice but
if you give them like you know a bunch
of outs they're going to take the outs
so with my daddy just smothered us with
like rules and and with backed by like
you know do not break this you know we
were like scared you know it's not like
he would beat us or anything but I mean
there was like this level of authority
that we were like oh this isn't so but
what level of authority was at that you
wouldn't disobey those those rules I
mean well I think you have to be you
have to be scared imposing yeah you have
to be scared of the cons scared of
physical consequences which I'm I don't
I don't think that's a bad thing I know
that I'm not supposed to say that I
think it helped my brother and I
immensely that uh our dad would you know
like well let me just be clear though
make sure that we didn't really good at
never hitting us ever in our entire
lives but always being physically
imposing and threatening enough that we
would like just not want to mess with
him you know and which I think is like
great fathering you know because you
never should touch your kid and he never
would I mean he might push us up against
the wall and scream and tell he peed our
pants practically but he would never
like ever hit us or hurt us ever yeah
you just have to be scared of like the
consequence I think like my mom our mom
would could not keep us in check and
then she would try to spank us or
whatever around us 50 different Little
Things it never worked sced plus when
she spanked like you know she'd spank us
with like spoons and we would just be
like you know once we realized like it
that it only hurt so much then she was
because then we would just sit there and
she just was hopeless and I I feel bad
but my dad like you know we felt like we
they were divorced at the time just to
be clear so yeah so he um yeah he
straightened us out when we were like 15
16 I mean like you're go through like
kind of the regimen well he would wake
us up at like 5:00 a.m. and we'd go in
the garage and work out so that would be
the like the start he you know took our
baggy clothes off our earrings off you
know shaved my goatee took out the
earring like he'd dress us um drop us
off at school pick us up from school
we'd go to his office where he was a you
know a professor at the you didn't miss
a class I mean it's like you don't just
do our HK Marines basically no friends
no time to get in trouble like literally
he made sure for the first year that we
had not even 10 minutes to ourselves so
we just couldn't get in trouble sounds
like a really intelligent person he also
he's also a marine and he learned that
and he teaches sociology and he's he's
quite introspective and he he was and
this isn't to say my dad's a better
parent than my mom it's just that he had
the skill set to control us as like you
know the types of kids that we were and
for my mom it was really difficult for
someone else my mom would have been you
know probably the perfect parent my dad
wouldn't have maybe you know been as
yeah we at it most kids don't need like
you know a physically imposing
consequence but we did because we were
pretty out of we didn't listen to
anybody whether it's a teacher or a
parent like we were just you know the
police like we just didn't care about
anything when did you start to enjoy
that structure that he was giving to you
or did you res during the time it was
always a nightmare it only about a year
until then then once he had us like you
know structured then he backed off and
then we had actually an unbelievable
amount of Freedom like then it was just
you know cart Blan once he trusted us it
was anything you want buy his kegs for
parties I mean it was like whatever cuz
he's like okay you're not going to miss
a class you're not doing drugs you're
not you're not drinking and driving
you're not doing these things and I know
you're not going D I trust you with that
and he was right to trust us we wouldn't
and then it's like okay do whatever you
want then we'll get I'll get you a house
I'll get you he he would rent us he
rented us a house and we would throw
parties like it was a frat house he
would get his kegs and stuff but how
does he have that confidence that you're
not going to slip back into those
routines that you had I think we just to
demonstrate a trust over time yeah and
we never did slip back in those routines
ever we were smart kids like almost
probably too smart so that's probably
why I think we were bored and we would
just act out but once we kind of got
more into school and we had more
structured environment then we started
apply in ourselves and he could tell
that we were not going to like you know
slip back did you realize that was just
a better way to live than the other way
so you made the own personal decision
like once I have this structure I tested
it out I got good results I like this
I'm going to stick with this or yeah I
think that's right you I think maybe but
also there was consequences if if we
ever did slip back cuz we would probably
lose the freedom oh that's a good point
you still did have those consequences he
just kind of allowed you to have more
freedoms right but first if you're on a
business I'm sure you're well aware just
how complicated things can get for
example the scheduling issue which is
exactly why Graham isn't in here with
the studio with me filming this I said
I'm sorry Jack trying to keep all your
goals tasks and data organized in
several different software sometimes
ends up actually taking more time than
it's worth if you're looking to
streamline your business but you aren't
sure where to start keep these three
numbers in mind from our sponsor Nets
week
3625 and 1 36,000 because 36,000
companies have already upgraded to
netsuite and stopped wasting time on
things like manual data entry and
sifting through scattered data 25
because netwe has spent 25 years helping
businesses Drive down their costs and
one because netsu is an all-in-one
solution that allows you to manage all
of your kpis or key performance
indicators with one efficient system
Nets can help reduce the mistakes from
manual data entry and prevent the busy
work from scaling with your business so
right now download netsuite's kpis
checklist for free check out
netsuite.com that's IED again that's
nets.com to get your free kpis checklist
once again completely free nets.com
thank you so much netsuite and back to
the episode and at what point did you
guys want to get into law pretty early
on I'd say like cuz we were you know
that whole argumentative nature that we
have cuz we thought we were going to be
like we wanted to be a car mechanic we
want to be this I would say maybe like
in college well I think we considered it
like kind of our whole lives cuz our mom
would always be like you guys stop
lawyering me you know what I mean cuz
that's how we'd argue it almost innate
for us to like argue like lawyers true
but we did want to be mechanics probably
until you know high school or even
through high school so I guess it was
always like maybe a tiny background
possibility but not really considered
until look I mean I think a lot of it
was what the hell are we going to do
we're about to graduate I'm not going to
get a job you know isn't that why a lot
of kids go to law school well but we
took pre-law in at Berkeley yeah an
undergrad so we wanted to be we Lov the
law just because it's like a I don't
know it's to me it kind of defines the
world you know in a way it's like it's
understanding the rules of society is
kind of a a good way to beat the rules
you know it's also the way our brains
work like some people's Brands work in
science and math that wasn't us yeah
we're very analytical and like you know
logical so it was we loved law school
not many people did but I really school
it kind of makes sense because it seems
like your entire life you were kind of
using authority to your own benefit and
understanding where you can slip through
the loopholes of authority very similar
to like understanding the laws and then
kind of like the flexibility of the laws
our brains exactly like yeah like like
professors want your brain to work it
does make sense that you would go into
that but it's funny how when you say
like we went into law it's like we went
into law it's not just like I it's like
it was a group kind
of a bilateral you know subconscious
maybe like agreement you know so was it
one of you guys that kind of spearheaded
that no I think no recollection I don't
remember I don't remember any it just
like just you guys both woke up on the
same exact morning and then just looked
at each other like we're going in no I
don't even it was very gradual I don't
remember any particular it probably a
gradual like you know let's take the
elsat that's probably just in case we
want to you know like okay sure let's
take the elide and then well you know
let's these poly side classes are we
should probably take some pre-lock
classes sure and then you know I mean I
guess we're can go to La school yeah
cool I don't know it's probably more
like that than it was like waking up in
the morning right and then you guys
ended up practicing law you presided
over like that Enron case which I like
we did a whole study of that in my
business law class which is really fun I
didn't know that you did that and then
you were the first one that was like I
want to be or you wanted to travel
travel yeah well I hated the law what
did you hate most about law I didn't
hate the law per se I hated being a
lawyer I hated being a corporate lawyer
I hated anything about Corporate America
it was like because I mean like think
listen to everything I've said you know
for the last half an hour about my
personality and then put me in a
box and have people just tell me what to
do that's essentially what it was and I
was like by box I mean like an office
granted it was you know with views in
the tallest building in the west coast
but it was still like a box and I was
absolutely miserable eating at me
psychologically like every day it was
absolutely miserable even to this day
it's like it's scarring even to think
about those years really yeah but by all
a available data like you probably were
making more money oh you had more status
than ever you had fed your ego right I
was one of the top law firms in the
country making 150k at 26 and 19 and
2000 or whatever I my own
secretary I was balling by any objective
measure how nervous were you to give
that up not very because I was so
miserable so it made the decisions
really easy after a while I just hit to
a point I remember I was like 3 years in
um they were trying to give me this [__]
ass case I mean absolutely just
disgusting case it was like one of those
cases that you know they just dread
giving to anybody but I just got sucked
into it and I just and I CU I didn't
wake up that morning thinking I was
going to leave and I just like you know
what no I'm done and I went back to my
office and I uh I drafted a resignation
email and walked into the managing
partner's office like an hour after this
like it literally it all happened to
that hour and I said uh I'm going to be
leaving the LA he's like oh what firm
are you going to lateral to I'm like no
no no I'm like I'm out I bought a one
way ticket to London I think during that
hour I [__] you not and he's like what
are you going to do I remember this
conversation actually he's like what are
you going to do you're not going to
transfer to another firm I'm like I'm
just going to travel and he's like
looked at me for a second and it was
like half confusion but half jealousy
you know and then he's like all right
well I wish you the best of luck and I
walked out and I was like I mean I put
in my I had two I had two weeks but I
mean pretty much that they didn't give
me the case I didn't like work another
hour right and I was like that was it it
was weird
did you have the savings to be able to
do that no so how did you fund the oh I
had a Jan Sport with my shoes dangling
from the shoelaces tight at the JanSport
and I just took off to Costa Rica and it
was the beginning of a fouryear journey
and I came make money for four years
well I did like a couple little things
in real estate uh I came back pretty
significant in debt with my bro and my
mom and my dad when I was done traveling
I was like 100k in debt it was you know
not the most genius idea on on paper
yeah but you know I look back at that
time as pretty pretty awesome you know
what's cool is a lot of people think
that in order to change you need to make
the change desirable but a lot of the
times it's just staying the same being
so undesirable that Spurs the change
rather yeah for me it was that
everyone's like oh my God you're so
you're so ballsy you're so how do you
how did you have the balls to do I was
like honestly like I couldn't take
another day it was it was the easiest
decision ever there's no balls necessary
you know that's the way I look at it
yeah and what prompted you to follow
that did you see him traveling or just
like
CU I'm more of a grinder so I can like I
can put my head down and I can grind
pretty hard so that's what I was doing
so I wasn't as unhappy as him um but
yeah seeing him traveling you know all
around the world I was like and within
about six months I I said I have to quit
too and then the economy took a [__] and
then everyone started traveling every
Banker lawyer and so it was like a group
of us yeah so we just friend traveling
with so we spent over three years just
traveling the world uh just sold
everything we owned you know literally I
think everything except a backpack and
some clothes we would come back to the
US you know every few months do some
laundry say hi to the family and we take
off again didn't have a winter for four
years we're not worried about making
money I was worried the whole the whole
time I I like a lowgrade background
anxiety the whole time you know which is
actually when I came back to the states
after four years I I got really run down
and sick for a long time like a year
really I think it was all that like
low-grade anxiety building up and just
eating at my hor hormonal system but not
to say I didn't enjoy those times but
yeah it wasn't physically probably
the greatest thing on my body I didn't
have that much anxiety I oh you were
just came back in 40 Grand yeah I left
with 100 Grand I'd saved over like four
years of being a lawyer 100 Grand which
is just embarrassing because you think
about what it takes to get a house right
now and I spent four years at like a top
law firm and you know I was making like
250 a year and I saved 100 Grand were
you just spending a whole bunch of money
no I wasn't I was living in a one
bedroom apartment for most of then how
did you not have money it's just hard to
save I mean you're make even if you're
making 200 Grand a year and you're
paying taxes you probably clear like 120
you spend you know probably at least 75
of that so you're saving like 30 if
you're gram it lives
on a day I wasn't gram you know I
brought my coffee from home so I save
some money on that yeah were you Frugal
or no no we've always no that's the
thing I picked up on like I heard you
guys have a crazy clothing budget like
it doesn't even we have a crazy
everything budget we definitely enjoy
spending money we enjoy having fun and
and the nice things in life so I would
say we're the opposite of frugal we also
have no kids no girlfriends no pets what
you kind of have pets I mean we don't
have that much responsibility so it's
like yeah okay fine but you know what I
mean we just don't have that much
responsibility so it's not like we're
blowing our kids inheritance or or not
being able to send them to college if we
like do something dumb but does part of
you think like you know I would like to
settle down I would like to you know buy
a ranch and then go be a like you know
what I mean no not not a single I mean
maybe
should I have should I have taken more
time on that so it didn't seem like no
no I I love the resounding no yeah I'm
pretty happy single I mean I have tried
you know a couple times but I'd say it's
probably in the future for me if I'm
going to settle down and I don't even
know if I will but if I'm going to get
married it's probably not going to be
anytime too soon but one of the main
arguments is that like it's kind of a
long-term investment you don't really
see the the the the growth the gains of
it until later down the line when you're
like 80 and you're like well I've been
with this person for 40 know so in we
have each other though so I but you guys
aren't kissing
right unless if maybe you I don't know
make up after the fight that's how you
solve the problem but get well go ahead
if you think about I think why a lot of
people get married or
are um wanting of a serious relationship
if you really get down to it I think
it's because they don't want to feel
alone in the world kissing it's not but
really though it's like being it's
having a someone to call when something
good
having someone to call when something
bad
happens someone's going to be there if
something ever goes wrong with your
health anything like just you're not
alone in the universe there you have
that that person I think that's why
people really seek these relationships
you can get sex or kissing elsewhere you
can't get what I'm talking about
elsewhere you need a partner you need
typically a partner you know like a
sexual partner like a wife or whatever
it is and if you have Rel if you already
have those needs fulfilled the nonsexual
ones then you know I think naturally the
desire for that disappears I'm
speculating the need that is so
fascinating that you say that because
because okay this is I don't know if I'm
getting a dicey territory here but the
type of emotional connection that I have
with a couple of my boys like my friends
the people that I am so close to is like
a hundred times what I have ever had in
my entire life with someone who I'm like
a like a intimate partner with you know
what I mean and now when you're saying
it it's like I mean you're just doing
what you want right you see the value
there and it's more valuable doing that
than finding a maybe some woman that you
don't have that emotional con we really
close relationships with many women and
men so we have like a very healthy like
friendships that I think so I get in
some ways so much from my friendships my
my brother that I would get in a
relationship but your emotional
stimulation and and that sort of stuff
is Satisfied by exactly I also just like
being alone tooo like it is awesome to
come home put my dog on my lap and watch
TV let me let me just I think I would be
more than able to connect to a partner
not in the same way we do emotionally
because we don't have the history but in
a way that's incredibly fulfilling I've
had some incredibly fulfilling
relationships with women psychologically
emotionally physically and in ways that
you know that I don't have with him it's
not that I can't get that and that I
don't enjoy that it's just that that
type of relationship other than the one
with your you know that I have with him
or the one that you have with your boy
there's massive compromise associated
with it that's the issue I don't think
issues that I can't connect in that way
or that I don't want to uh it's the the
compromise that comes with it I don't
compromise [__] with him if he tells me
to do something I tell him the [__] off
he's not really good at at I'm much
better at compromising your boys seems
so I'm better in relationships like I
can just be your boys don't make you
compromise do they I mean no you know so
and a girlfriend does so that's the
difference or a wife certainly does
would you guys ever live in the same
house no we would fight we've tried we
lived in the same house for a couple
years we fought every day oh it's brutal
so no we'll never live in the same house
he's like a child the way even working
together can't even work in the same
office yeah it's tough if it wasn't for
his assistant and his like inh house
basically Nanny his house would be a
disaster oh my God living with him was a
disaster I'm like really I imagine you
to be so clean I would see everything gu
now I don't like I don't clean but but
yeah here's the thing like if if his I
call her a
nanny isn't isn't there adult Nanny if
if she doesn't show up for 3 Days the
sink is like he literally won't
she's coming back on Friday I'm like
dude but it doesn't mean you can't like
you know that's that's so imagine that
but with no nanny living with that but
with no nanny it's brutal I will not do
a dish I haven't I it will sit in the
sink until Monday and that gives me
anxiety like one dish in the sink is me
I was like my place has to be spotless
so it was brutal living with him I've
never thought like I feel like a very
fulfilling life could just be living
near doesn't have to be in the same
house as like your boys right and then
you get all the Fulfillment and satis
you need out of that and then elsewhere
you can find else you we very fulfilled
I would say I mean we are very two very
happy people I would say very fulfilled
um and we get we're very close with our
family very close with both male and
female friends we have each other and we
have great relationships when we're in
them um so yeah I mean we yeah we do
have great female relationships just not
like the the long-term monogamous but
outstanding relationships with women
have you always been good with women
I've been curious about this um a whole
life just at what at what age did that
start that you realize hey
maybe um we yeah at an early age yeah
yeah but I wouldn't say until maybe High
School I started like batting out of my
league I guess you would call it I don't
know u in high school yeah it wasn't
like I was like I wasn't dating the
cutest girl in the school in middle
school or but we always our weight class
and say with women and how do you do
that what what ask that all the time I
have no idea that that's in your bones
yeah you'd have to ask the women that we
date it's hard for me to answer that
that just has to be in your natural
personality your natural demeanor your
natural conf a lot of it's confidence
but again we weren't coached in
confidence we just a lot of this is is
in your bones I'm not to say you can't
improve as a person but speaking from I
mean correct me if you disagree but I I
was born that way and I'm not bragging
I'm lucky you know do you feel like I
still think it's I think I don't think
it's uh nature as much as nurture I
think you're minimizing the influence
our parents had but I think it is nature
nurture do you think your height has
held you back or made it better for you
in such a way that you stand out I'd say
neither you know I don't think about it
I don't I think if we were 63 with these
personalities we would it would be scary
it would be scary yeah I think God only
gives you so much you know and we don't
really I've never we don't really dwell
on things you know so I don't really
think about it that yeah I'll go like
years without thinking about maybe
that's why it doesn't matter cuz it
doesn't matter to us but then all of a
sudden it doesn't matter like I've
definitely been with women who Chelle is
a perfect example she would if you had
talked to her before she met me she
would have never been with someone under
like 62 63 so sometimes you know the
women just don't expect it then yeah
I've been with women that like tall guys
I've been with six foot multiple dated
multiple women 6 feet tall it is really
I think what they're attracted to is
your personality and your the way you
carry yourself I'll give you an example
um I went to the a doctor's office years
ago new doctor had never met him and I
was in the chair waiting for me he came
up and he you know shook my hand like
you we were standing and I shook his
hand and we talked for a little bit and
then we both sat back down and he was
like taking my you know weight eye color
whatever height he's like what are you
like 5'11 6 and I thought he was [__]
with me you know I'm like yeah and he's
like how tall are you I'm like bro I we
just met I was stud right I was I'm 55
he's like oh I don't know I just you
struck me like after meeting I just F
like you were six feet tall and I I
think that's how women like look at it
they just I mean yeah some women really
don't like the height issue but honestly
if you just naturally have like an aura
about you of like I don't give a [__]
how tall I am and and trust me I'm
you're going to you know I'm you're not
going to regret dating me they don't
they don't they don't get a [__] nobody
really does yeah it's interesting you
guys do surround yourself with very tall
people a lot of people in the office
were all like six foot and they also
wear heel all the time heels you know a
lot of my friends are I don't even
notice how you know I I had a friend
well Omar and I had they're both I think
6'4 yeah I had no idea I think I was
asking them for some reason how tall
they were and he said 6'4 I'm like what
like if you would asked me the day
before I would like 510 like I don't see
height cuz almost everyone's taller than
me right which by the way uh that
reminds me because there's very few
people that can wear my clothes but I
have clothes that don't fit me anymore
so I'm going to give them to you they're
nice too right cuz I know you won't buy
yourself nice St on the Pod cuz this
thing's okay I'll go get them and give
them to this whole this whole outfit by
the way I think this is yours RS uh
pants Jason he wears your clothes every
single time I come over he's like I got
him this new outfit and he goes he goes
it's nice every single when I saw this
I'm like are you sure this doesn't fit
me cuz oh my God your best piece ofo CRA
this is this is a suede St laurant
jacket I wore it one time no way dude
I'm so pissed it doesn't fit me and then
matching St La uh pants cuz I tailored
them too much that's like a $3,500
jacket
and it's going to fit you like a glove I
knew it look at that come on that is
insane if any wealthy viewer has some
old clothes that doesn't fit them
anymore please reach out to me oh my
gosh DM me that's crazy thank you I
tried to I tried to let the arms out
perect I know that's crazy I took it to
the Tor last week I'm like take the the
sleeves out cuz my arms are getting too
big and they said they can't so I'm like
[__] Graham I know a guy with really
small arms that's why I stop working do
not edit that out of the out of
the so this nonf frugality that you guys
have is very funny when you jux suppose
it with Grahams insane FR insane
frugality still doesn't get double
chicken when we go to Chipotle and he
just asks for a little bit more instead
and hopes that they don't charge him
it's insane I love it about I would take
him to lunch every day when we were
agents together and we'd go to like the
you know Chipotle or what's that tokaya
Taya and he would I was paying so he
would get like a large lunch and he
would eat half of it and then he would
box it half up and if anyone at the
table he would always grab everything
that everyone left and put it in the Box
for his dinner yeah every single day or
the next day I remember I asked you once
I was like dude how much do you have to
be worth for you to like go into a
Trader Joe's or because you'll never go
into Whole Foods and just not give a
[__] what the blueberries cost or what
the what nothing C just not give a [__]
you know and and he's like 100
million dude I think he'll always
remember when we 50 million maybe 50 I
think it went down to 50 I think I
talked him down to 50 inflation though
you might bring $20 blue we went
gambling and he lost like 20 bucks on
Blackjack and he was devastated oh it
ruins his night I was like dude you have
a problem Furious when he and he like
balls up his fist and like so upset yeah
he's scared he's going to hit me or
something that's a joke that's a joke
but yeah he does get very upset when he
loses money or has to SP did you learn
that or is that in your bones I think
that was in my bones I think I've always
just so now you know what I mean when I
say something's in my bones it's like
you have to beat that out of me we're
literally the opposite I have never been
concerned about money I've always always
felt like I'll be successful so I've
just always spent like I've had it even
when I didn't I mean when I was uh when
I graduated law school I had no no money
obviously I was in a little bit of debt
and I took my summer associate paychecks
and I went to a lender and I bought a
$100,000 SL 500 Mercedes and I hadn't
even passed the bar exam yet so I had1
$110,000 car I put zero money down this
is back when you could do that in like
in early 2000s and I pulled up as a
first year well luckily I passed the bar
and pulled up as a first year associate
driving the nicest car entire parking
gar from really we went from $300 cars
to just like $100,000 why did you need
that though why that I just enjoyed it I
thought it was a cool car like I've
always could we've always just you know
spent like we were going to be
successful I don't necessarily Rec this
is not this is horrible advice say to
make that don't follow this also the
thing is oddly enough I don't think we
cared and when we came back from
traveling we we we left very prestigious
you know successful and financially
rewarding jobs came back I was driving
my grandpa's like 1974 like gold linoln
Navigator it was overheating all the
time it was like a $900 car I actually
sold it for $900 um at it to a gas
station and I didn't care like I was
living in a one-bedroom apartment with
Alex like you know going back between
the bed and the uh couch like every
month I was still happy when we our
happiest years you know we're really
happy now but we were you know working
on our hot rods and eating you know uh
eating burritos out of the you know
Roach Coach and just wearing you know
tank tops and going to the gym and no
money and no cares I mean I I think
we've never been concerned about being
there there was a year where we went to
Subway 360 of the 365 days because they
had like dollar 6 in sandwiches and
whatever the dollar 6inch sandwich was
that day we we were super happyy like we
had our friends we would just work out
we had our you know our hot rods where
do you get that inner confidence from I
confidence
it's just to I never thought things
would but you were comfortable if they
like it didn't matter if you were back
on someone's couch in somebody's
apartment right well it would matter if
I was a failure like it would matter if
I wasn't successful successful or
working towards something which one no
I'm okay working towards something okay
but I would not be happy and I would not
be able to live with myself if I wasn't
becoming successful becoming there we go
if I didn't see like a growth you know
pattern for myself so it doesn't mean
that I you know can eat from a food
truck every day I'm fine with that as
long as I know that I'm I'm working
towards something can can I give you a a
esoteric but really interesting example
if if it might be a bit hard to follow
but if you really get it I think it's
like one of the best things you can
learn in life if I can get this correct
they they did um they did testing on
experiment on mice and there was three
different groups of mice again it's
horrible that they do this but just
follow the so so 50 mice 50 mice in like
three different cages I guess and they
would subject them they they gave all
150 mice uh serum that gave him a 50%
chance of getting cancer okay brutal but
just follow they subjected the mice to
different I'm going to try to get this
right um sets of electric shocks okay
and the electric shocks so there was
there was 50 that got no electric shocks
just the serum so 24 of the 50 got
cancer right around 25 of them got got
cancer then there was 50 mice that were
that were subjected to Electric shocks
randomly they could do nothing about it
the mice just they couldn't do anything
they just got electric shocks every once
in a while and then there was 50 mice
that got electric shocks but if they ran
over to a pedal and pushed the pedal the
electric shocks would stop but they were
subjected to and this is important the
same amount of aggregate electric shocks
than the 50 mice that couldn't that
didn't have the pedal okay so same
amount of electric shocks but 50 of the
mice had
no umol no control over their their
outcomes no control over stuff the
shocks and 50 of the mice had an
illusion of control they could go push
the pedal and stop the shocks but they
were still getting the same amount of
shocks the 50 mice that had no control
of the um of their lives essentially 80%
of them got cancer just because of the
the psychological wear of that of that
you know basically torture I already
told you 50% of the mice that got no
shocks got the cancer because the serum
give you a 50% chance of getting cancer
the 50 mice that got shocked but had the
an an illusion of control over their
lives that could push the pedal and stop
the shocks temporarily got less cancer
than the group of mice that had no
electric shocks at all and I think
that's very true if if you can follow
that with humans you don't have to have
a good life you have to feel like you're
in control of your of your future like
you have a sense of purpose it is not
amount of electric shocks in your life
you know just whatever is coming at you
in life that makes you happy or or makes
you even physically healthy it is just
and so he can be on a couch or whatever
it is rotating with his friend that it's
not the circumstances per se that make
your life happy or make it even um
healthy for your physical being it's
your illusion of okay I'm going
somewhere or I am I'm in the process of
becoming successful or I feel like
empowered in some way I feel like I have
a sense of purpose and then you can even
have a shittier life than a lot of other
people but you're actually physically
healthier and happier if that it does
make it's a weird way to but I when I
read this this my study it like blew my
mind and it's so able to human beings
like we were as happy in junior college
you going to edit that out was that just
a ramble I loved it and I've actually
heard some I think I heard that study or
a study it's a famous study that's been
duplicated and it's really has
interesting findings if you get into it
but good yeah I'm just saying like is
happy as I'd say we are now I think that
we were equally happy you know when we
were 20 years old at Community College
you know with no money you know sleeping
on a couch but working towards law
school you know working our way through
school because we had a purpose like we
knew where we were going so we had a
plan and you know we just had friends we
were hanging out working out and so such
amazing years we've never needed you
know success or you know a ton of money
I never thought I would be this you know
financially successful but I've been
happy for a long time you know well
before I had any success just because I
had good friends and I I had a plan do
you I mean have you heard of like the
the happiness Baseline the theory that
everybody has a certain happiness
Baseline it's predetermined by the time
you're born and then throughout life
obviously you'll go above it you'll go
beneath it but generally speaking you're
always going to return to your Baseline
some people's baselines are very low
it's like a two or a three five being
average seven maybe you're a pretty
happy person some people are just happy
all the time and something horrible can
happen to them maybe they like lose an
arm or something like that and they'll
go down but then they end up going right
back to that Baseline do you believe in
that or do you think that the Baseline
can be adjusted and you can truly make
long-term effects on your happiness
levels over time oh I definitely think
you can I mean you can have a good
relationship um you know a uh healthy
you know relationship with your family
you can have financial success um
there's a lot of things that can improve
your Baseline I think for sure but but
also I agree with I think there's a lot
of Merit in what you're saying I don't
think that those two things can't live
in the same world what you're saying and
what he yeah I agree with the Baseline
now there are some people who are just
naturally little Happ depressed and
there some people who are naturally just
I think there's a lot of Merit to that
you can definitely adjust it yeah what
he's saying is you can adjust it you can
go from a two to a seven right you know
but uh but I think I think there's a lot
of Merit to that yeah I've just noticed
some people people like especially
growing up you know with people I went
to elementary school with like they
seemed happy back then and they've
always continued to be happy even
through pretty trag tragic events that
have happened in their life and they say
stay the exact same there are people who
let life happen to them and then there
are people who like create their life if
you're like I would say that we're
people who just create our life but
maybe you were predetermined to do that
and and that is I think that's true
indicative of a higher Baseline you know
I think that's right I think people with
purpose are generally happier so um in
that sense you can if you give yourself
self purpose or you find purpose in your
life you can increase your Baseline but
I do think there are people with low
baselines that can make a lot of good
decisions and work really hard towards
being happy and it's it's 10 times as
hard for them to be happy as it is for
somebody who's naturally happy so there
I think there's a lot of Merit to that
there's also a problem there cuz we had
hormos on the podcast he said one thing
that really stuck out to me which is
like if you think that achieving a
certain something will make you happy
you are creating a dissonance between
where you are currently and what you
need in order to become happy and
therefore you're placing all the
importance in the ends and not
necessarily in the means and the people
that are truly happy in this life pay
place all the importance on the means no
a lot of people don't enjoy the process
they are they're so focused on yeah
there there are very few people that
like oh when I'm 65 I'm going to retire
and I'm be everything's like you know at
that and they don't really enjoy it up
to that point none of those people are
when they get the retirement when they
get the whatever it is they're always
like what the really this was what it
about you said I really liked it was
that every 6 months every 3 to six
months you re-evaluate where your
happiness is on a scale and if it's
going down you you change your
circumstances so that you'll be happier
and you do this in business
relationships friendships whatever it
might be I found that really insightful
I think it's really helpful for people
what metrics do you use to gauge your
happiness I'm I I'm guessing you
probably do something similar right just
we do wonder I I ask a lot of uh I ask a
lot of my friends like I'll be like hey
how um you know how's your happiness
been the last 6 months one to 10 and
then you know some people will hem and
ha well be like it's up and down I'm
like I know I know but just overall um I
do that to my myself all the time like I
make sure that I'm at least a seven if
I'm going several months and my average
happiness isn't a seven then I I adjust
something what do you adjust like do you
know it could it could be relationship
it could be work um it could I I have to
analyze why I'm not happy I could go you
know I see a therapist uh so they
probably know you pretty intimately as
well they're like hey I noticed you're
spending a lot of time lately on this or
you're missing out on this and you're
getting influences like you're asking
people maybe like hey what does it seem
like I'm lacking and then they give that
yeah I mean I will see a therapist and
kind of like walk through what's going
on and you found good results from
diagnosing the issue and truly actually
solving the underlying yeah I'd say I
mean I can adjust my happiness like
about a point just by like maybe I'm
working too hard you know um maybe I
need more vacation maybe uh I'm not you
know happy in a relationship or maybe um
I need more purpose or maybe I want to
you know or maybe I'm spending too much
I mean I'll just figure out like why I'm
a little off-kilter you haven't been
working out maybe yeah or maybe I
haven't been I realiz too much too
little so what I find interesting in
that is the underlying belief that you
have not total but a lot of control over
your just general happiness because I
feel like it's kind of a taboo topic now
where a lot of people think that like
you just kind of are a product of the
environment and you can't necessarily
take control of your own happiness and
do certain things and oh you go to the
gym you wake up at this time you drink a
lot of water this will actually make you
happy lot is that a product of our times
I'm not keen to that I mean it's like a
thing now like like personal development
self-development and stuff like that
people toss it out the window they think
like oh that's a bunch of I think there
has become a very significant victim
mentality going on right now in society
where I think people rather than take
the initiative and and not make excuses
people are making excuses for themselves
a lot I and maybe this is just my
perspective but I do feel like a lot of
people these days are making excuses as
opposed to like the way we grew up we
would not make excuses for ourselves we
would just go fix it and we're also not
types to like listen to self-help stuff
we're just like it's not that
complicated to go to the gym and go out
socially and just do basic things that
are good for your body and your soul
it's not you don't I don't personally
need to listen to a 14-part uh series on
or or read books on that kind of stuff
it's funny that was one of the the big
clips from Andrew Tate was that if you
feel bad about yourself or if you're
depressed go to the gym and get a
six-pack and then come back and see your
happiness level and how fulfilled you
are and in those cases I'm sure lot of
people who just go to the gym and work
on getting a six-pack and just have one
goal to work towards find themselves
thinking if I could achieve that one
thing I could do this and this and this
and all the doors seem to open up I've
heard Jordan Peterson say clean your
room yeah it's the same concept I agree
with that clean your room make your bed
go to the gym go out to a bar by
yourself if you don't have friends just
do basic [__] and don't just don't have
a victim mentality just do it and you
don't need to read a book or listen
to so fascinating that you say like you
don't look into self-help yet it appears
like you guys are very happy and healthy
people one of I feel like the most
mentally healthy or friend that I have
that I've known for a very long time I
asked him because I had been going
through like the self-help phase where
I'm reading all these personal
development books Etc and he was like
yeah I threw all that stuff out the
window I stopped reading it and he's
like it's all just a bunch of mumbo
jumbo you just have to be happy which
obviously it's very easy to say that
which is it's interesting but it seems
as though it actually works for me I do
think that there is I will give Credence
to those who say the happiest people are
the ones who do not read the
self-development books because Seekers
will always you know happy people that
are always looking reading self-help
books that are super happy I feel like
it could get you on the right path
though it can give you some tools
necessary but it doesn't fix it and if
you think it's going to fix it then
you're in for a rude away I think maybe
that's the issue they think it's going
to fix it and and there's another uh
thing that was in a book self-help
ironically that I read which is that
Seekers will always be Seekers you just
have to be a finder you know what I mean
don't don't always think that this you
you have to find it's like taking
different vitamins instead of eating
well and also think there's a there's a
kind of a get-rich quick mentality to it
meaning like you're trying to get an
easy answer and most often in life there
aren't easy answers most often it's just
hard work and people don't want to like
recognize that they want to think that
there's some trick I mean people come up
to me like oh you know how can I be
successful in real estate like as though
I can just tell them something in 10
seconds it's going to make it easy I how
about work your [__] ass off for the
next decade but nobody wants to hear
that yeah I want to know about the
abundance mentality that I see in you
guys this is something I talk to Graham
about a lot actually because I think
obviously there are a bunch of different
groups of people but I I see the main
two as abundance versus scarcity
mentality people Graham I think is is
very clear he's a scarcity mentality
person I'm not saying one is better than
the other okay but I do think that
there's some like you feel like a weight
is lifted off of your shoulders you can
see someone they look less stressed out
when they're an abundance mentality
person you know what I mean where do you
guys think this abundance mentality
originated and I'm sure seeing a lot of
wealthy people all of the time as agents
Brokers Etc um You probably see these
two archetypes right the abundance
mentality person I got to be honest I
never use classifications like that
because I feel like everything's on a
scale in society I think there's a a
huge like reaction to try to there's two
different typ three different types
there I don't think there ever is in in
pretty much anything I think every human
being is we're just on a scale of one to
100 on everything I don't think there's
ever but I do I think that there is
Merit in saying that like if there was a
spectrum you have abundance and scarcity
like right and I'm not just labing
because of course you can have probably
a scarcity thought here and there and he
can there people that are I mean I don't
even um I mean I agree with the camps to
some degree um but I think that there
are people who are just always scared
you know or concerned and there are
people who just aren't you know and are
and will take more risks like we've
always been Risk Takers cuz we don't
we're not scared people um and so I
think that's helped us out a lot just
always taking risks do you see an over
overall difference in like the general
fulfillment and happiness levels of
people who come or Who air more on the
side of an abundance mentality or the
scarcity mentality because they both are
actually good in and of themselves
because they SP they SP what's your Happ
1 to 10 what's my happiness I'd say some
days a six some days last average last
six months probably a six I would say
which a little lower cuz you work too
hard or what uh I would personally I
think it's lack of a direction and lack
of feeling like as bit
I I've talked before about being in the
flow state where it's just like you're
just zoning in on one thing have not
found what that thing is for me yet I
love the podcast but it's not something
I could do 10 hour about the last five
years up until the last six months uh
probably eight overall that's that's the
mouse that has the pedal versus the
mouse that doesn't yeah right right or
or does that not make sense no it it
does what having control my life you had
the pedal the last five years until six
now you don't have no now now I have a
pedal it's just I have so many pedals to
pick from that it's it's like figureing
out what I want to
yeah exactly
which when I when I talked to you 5
years ago you wanted to be in this
position five years ago so it's
interesting how now you're looking back
and you were happier then cuz you were
like oh I need to slow down like I can't
keep this pace up you wanted more time I
was happiest when I came to you and I'm
like dude I'm too busy and you're
telling me to ease back I'm like no I
have to keep going I was happiest I
don't think there's a big difference in
the between the scar set and the
abundance as far as happiness I don't
think that's what defines your your
happiness very much at all that's
interesting
sense of purpose to me sense of purpose
and control over your life but I would
say that if you're if if that sense of
scarcity gives you anxiety um then it's
going to make youy make difference I
mean I think that there are both just
tools that people use to be productive
to get things done is out of scarcity or
out of a bun as I just can but and and
that's interesting so you said you're at
a six right now but over the past five
years you've been at eight you said so
when have you everever been been below a
five because five would be average right
so that would mean you know within the
standard deviation like most of your
time 80 7% or whatever I I don't know
how usually we end up cutting out the
personal bits so I'm happy to talk about
it but um yeah I I think a lack of
challenge for me is is the big thing is
is I don't have that challenge of the
newness of something that I could work
on but you're still above average
overall yeah because he has a good
objective life you know above average
for yourself I'm not asking like
relative to other people yeah yeah above
average for myself overall but recently
I'd say the last six months has been
just a lack of Direction because I feel
like I've done what I set out to do
what's next I think that's an answer
that a lot of people would give it's
that's why when people retire sometimes
are less happy yeah yeah um you do need
that's why I like you know as much as I
don't want to like go open up another
office I'll go open up another office
because it gives me that sense of
purpose and Direction you know and uh
responsibility and I kind of thrive on
like projects that that's what I was
saying earlier this whole this whole
mentality which I think is fading now
but our parents definitely embraced it
of like I'm going to do all this until
I'm 65 and then retire it never works
because they always like either get
depressed or like die pretty pretty much
you know 5 years after they retire
because they have no sense of purpose
and they're just this is everything I
worked for my whole life it's a it's
just a horrific mentality to take in
life you just got to look at your life
as as like one long journey and not like
two a journey to 65 and then just
chilling it's just never never a good
outlook Graham's got everything he could
possibly want right now and you're a six
instead of an eight and you had less
when you were an eight so it's the you
so it has nothing to do with that you
were saying that earlier like people a
lot of people say I'll be happy when M
and that when never arrives because it
does arrive and there's another when M
so you're inevitably not going to be
happy so if you have to really just
enjoy the process which is why every six
months I look back and I think we you
know you do too and just kind and it's
important to tell the viewers it's not
money that that makes you happy I know
to an extent it
is yeah but I mean all the psychological
studies show this like dramatically it's
it's not like Brett oppenheim's opinion
there's a certain amount of money I
don't know exactly what it is where you
you don't have to Super stress on your
bills and things of that nature and you
can go to Trader Joe's and not and get
the blueberries and not care about it
Graham's not at that L wealth yet he's
getting there and then where you know
there's a lot of stress taken off you
and between that and a billionaire the
level of happiness is almost completely
unrelated to money so you don't have to
when diminishing returns is a few I
think St are like 350 350 but it it
varies the point is I think it's way
lower that it's literally I it was like
100 I think it's like di it's enough to
be able to pay your electric
blue perfect example I mean I we're
pretty damn happy I mean I'd say you
know maybe even an eight you know on
average um but I would say that some of
the best years of our lives are at least
also an eight were when we had no money
you know and we were like in High School
Junior College college just you know
struggling around with it but with our
buddies I had the gym you know uh and I
had a car and that's all I needed so I
think and we did we did not we were not
making 100 Grand a year so I think like
you said as long as you just don't have
the stress like you have a place to go
home and you can feed yourself you know
it's really and then it's diminishing
returns after that not to say that like
my you know 1965 Bronco doesn't make me
happy because it [__] does I love it
all of our wealthy clients are no
happier on average than a lot of our
friends that don't have money say it's
more about relationship like if you have
good friendships you're probably going
to be happier than a wealthy person
what's something that you notice between
your wealthiest clients that you'd say
they all tend to have in terms of maybe
a personality
how much money um I would say it's
always interesting to me that my wealthy
clients don't spend their money you know
they're Frugal uh or at least to me they
are wealthiest like I mean I would say
that
90% of my clients who are wealthy and
you know that varies from a million
dollars to you know a billion dollars um
90% of them don't spend money in the
manner that I think that they could and
should but do you see like within that
range a certain conent like the ultra
Ultra ultra wealthy percentage of your
clients are extra Frugal or is it just
generally speaking wealthy people say
people with a lot of money you would
think like but just spend it like I do I
mean what's the point of it I mean even
if I had kids you know yeah I'd make
sure that my kids had enough money but
um I just it's interesting to me like
I'll go out let's say and buy a very
expensive 1965 Ford Bronco because I
[__] love it that objectively is fun
to drive and I've got a lot of clients
wealthier than me that would like never
pay that kind of money for a Bronco and
I'm like why you could easily afford
that and it's fun like why would you not
do something different personalties it's
just interesting but I think why a lot
of people don't spend a lot of money is
because making money is like a game I
think a lot of people I would say maybe
mostly men but because they have maybe
have like more game mentality in their
brains but I think that they just go
through life saying I want to accumulate
as much as I can not because I need it
not because I want to spend it it's just
it's like a game the more money I'm
winning you know it's like points and so
if they spend their points then they
don't have as many points even though it
doesn't matter because they have enough
points to live a 50 times but it's just
like this point mentality and another
thing it's wrong I feel like a lot of
men in particular just have this like
this mentality through life I want to
accumulate as many points as possible
those are the rules and I want to you
know consider myself a winner and it's
not even like it's not a bad thing I
just that's the way they look at money I
think does that make sense that's pretty
accurate I would say fun fun
accumulating points like with you like I
I think you and all of my you know
wealthy people my clients and friends to
just spend more I mean it is objectively
fun to fly all your uh your friends to
Cabo like which I'm doing this week and
get place I'm sure but I worry is that
sustainable like if your income drops to
zero tomorrow could you doing I don't
like to do things that I know I can't
continue so if I get something because I
I worry if I level up my life I I don't
want to ever go
downar that's the scarcity mentality and
I think I mean like for example like I
will fight first class even though it's
obnoxiously expensive and it doesn't
make any sense related to what a coach
ticket costs but like what's the point
of having money if you're not going to
fly first class but then I feel like you
could slowly level up over time like if
my life gets 3% better every year in
terms of a lifestyle then I know I could
look forward in 10 years I don't have a
problem I don't have a problem with your
mentality I think your mentality makes a
lot of sense I do I wouldn't dissuade
people from that and towards yours at
all in fact if anything I probably
dissuade people towards grams I think
there's something about your personality
and and maybe to a slightly lesser
extent but pretty similar in my
personality that just we get a lot of
enjoyment and things from that I'm not
sure I would push that on other people I
think objectively on paper your your
scenario makes a lot more sense although
I think you could I think you take it to
the extreme but whatever but I have seen
too with my own clients that the
wealthier they are the less likely they
are to spend the money and the first
deal I ever did was in the Flats on
lynon drive and it sold I think at three
and a half million bucks cash first deal
yeah three and5 million cash and the guy
was probably spending another $2 to $3
million renovating the entire place and
like tearing down most of the thing but
I remember with him he was even
negotiating the inspection on the house
to get that inspection charge down and
I'm talking like saving a 100 bucks
and6 million you probably gravitate
towards those clients I love he was
great better point maybe than spending
money is
um I think at the very least take away
the annoyance that that can be caused by
having to pay attention to money like I
have not looked at a restaurant bill in
years so that for me is just peace of
mind I haven't looked at a credit card
statement in years am I getting screwed
probably every after this airs but I
don't mind like that's the point is I
don't want to have to look at a
restaurant bill you know all the bills
like exra I probably have a I have no
idea but that's for me like you know or
somebody or my you know Gardener or I
just got a text like they're like oh
your sprinkler at Hercules isn't working
and they want to you know it's like $900
I'm like fine I don't want to have to
review that invoice am I getting screwed
a couple hundred maybe I don't I don't
care that's the beauty of of having
money so if you can't if you still are
grinding if you're still looking at this
invoice and you're saying hey how much
of this is you know labor how much of
this is materials you know is that sod
really you know $12 a square foot I can
get it for $10 rude that's what's
happened to me and that's where I spent
a lot of my time I recently had a guy uh
to remove a little pipe and charge $600
and I said no because I know it's maybe
a $75 I used to I used to be like that
but then I thought to myself so what's
the worst case scenario the worst case
scenario is that I'm getting screwed a
couple hundred and which I can totally
afford and this guy is getting an extra
couple hundred so he can go to the
movies take his wife out to dinner fine
then I'm getting screwed and this guy's
having a slightly better life great I
mean I don't that's not a problem for me
and so if I just if I just reverse it
instead of me getting screwed it's like
me just being nice and I get enjoyment
out of that he gets I mean I don't
mind I don't I if the waitress charged
me for two stakes instead of one and the
I don't care like that to me if you're
wealthy and you're still worried about
this type of [__] then then you're not
getting advantage of your wealth to me I
guess it's more of a principal thing cuz
sometimes they'll shove the house you
got get away that's if you're still
worried about principal then you're not
allowing your money to make you happy
sure you just got to get over the whole
getting screwed you got to get over the
principal people are he's so focused on
principal like he a waiter will you know
not will screw up and he'll like I'm
like bro you don't need to complain
maybe he's like well the next person
will get the right sell dressing like
who gives a [__] it's not your job job
to like have to fix everything I just
stopped doing that I'm so much happier
now at what dollar amount do you do you
start paying attention like 10,000
20,000 I'm probably not a good uh answer
because I don't care really like for me
I go to an extreme and just you know not
stressing about anything like that to me
is the beauty of money is not stressing
so I don't stress about anything when
did that start at what point I've been
that way even when I didn't have money
really yeah which is dangerous you know
luckily have money now that sounds like
true wealth you know what I mean like if
if we're maybe being a little bit more
flexible with the definition of the word
wealth but our clients have way more
money than than like when when we go to
dinner I buy I haven't not bought a
dinner in years you know whether we went
to dinner last night with nine people I
bought dinner I will never not buy
dinner because I can I mean I don't if
you have some wealth and why would you
not buy dinner for everyone like I think
the wealthiest person should just buy
everything you know because it affects
them the least and yet you know I have
wealthy clients that just don't do that
I'm like what what's I don't get the
point then it's not a wealth thing
because that's a mentality thing that he
takes to the extreme but our clients are
all
most of our a lot of our clients are
wealthier than us some of them far far
far wealthier that's more of a mentality
thing that's interesting I don't
necessarily well I guess I agree with it
if like he also has a lot of confidence
that he's always going to be creating
wealth and he doesn't have much
responsibility beneath them so you know
this isn't exactly like the perfect
mentality for every well like an example
my mom is building like a a she shed in
her backyard and she's was I was I
called her she's and she's like stress
out over this invoice she's like well
Jason should I care this the Gardener
charged me $50 for knee pads you know
but but he's going to take those with
him you know after the job so I
shouldn't have to pay for those I'm like
oh my God Mom like you have money why
would you let the I so so you bought
your Gardener knee pads who gives a [__]
like to me it's like why would you ever
spend 15 seconds of your life worrying
about something like that who cares our
mom is more like you yeah not to S it's
so frustrating to me though I'm like but
it seems point we leased her in Mercedes
and she is like been over the moon for
the last seven years of driving it I'm
like could afford a mer you know you can
afford a Mercedes right yeah but it's
doing the things like that that she
wouldn't do for herself I'd be the same
way my point like she will reveal we
would do it for herself an invoice and
she'll you know and she'll see a $50
charge for knee pads that you know the
gardener is going to take with him and
that will cause her anxiety and stress
and she's feeling like it's unfair like
I don't know I'm just so it seems like
your life is completely designed around
minimizing stress anything you could do
to pay for that inconvenient you just
pay it it doesn't matter you don't want
to be stressed that's for me that's the
beauty of having he has a lot of stress
so like if you don't you should you
might as well and I'm not saying you
don't but you might as well then try to
maybe save some money and focus on that
but if if you're just being bombarded
with different inputs of stress all day
long and you can with through money
that's coming in more than you're
spending if you can minimize the stress
down here by spending some of that money
that's coming in then that probably
makes sense from like utilitarian
perspective it does seem like burgers or
anything or just that yeah I have some
it does seem like though you are
stressed about a lot of like real estate
deals Renovations managing hit theil the
head uh the stress that I that I enjoy
like I enjoy work stress because I love
work I don't enjoy personal stress so I
avoid it or I pay my way through it for
real bro I half of it man are we getting
I was all excited and this is get you
guys fighting half eaten folded Burger
why did you fold the burger dude oh I
didn't just you wonder why we fight he's
an idiot that looks [__] good it bite
after bite share
it how is it is it good you're welcome
the fries are [__] now really yeah yeah
cold fries are tough yeah okay one thing
that you were talking about uh there's a
lot of media on you so it's really easy
I'm guessing you're probably like you
said somewhat you're very similar you
share a lot of philosophies perspective
Etc um you were saying on some sort of
an interview that perspective is the
most important thing when you're
considering and adjusting your happiness
levels right something akin to that I'd
say perspective is probably the most
important thing to create happiness and
it's also the hardest thing to get you
can't buy perspective you can buy almost
everything and and you also are you the
one that does all the research and
Graham just sits here and basically not
his head Graham does a good amount of
research but sometimes I go a little
over Jack has a good perspective because
I know you guys it's hard for me to ask
questions that I know answers to versus
Jack has a good balance because he has
very little knowledge and experience and
and you very you have very little
knowledge actually INE that I let that
SL that you said that we're cutting that
part out I said something earlier that
was horrible I said Graham you'd have to
beat that out of me in some other Contex
I was like that probably didn't
someone's going to clip just that little
part you you you're saying perspective
will always change if you climb the
socioeconomic hierarchy something akin
to that and other hierarchies of Life uh
how do you keep your perspective in
check and make sure it still has a
positive impact on yourself I'm probably
not great at keeping perspective I mean
if I had perspective I'd probably my
level of Happiness would probably be a
10 all the time but you get jaded you
know you you're just like you know your
your perspective changes so Things
become normalized and then you take them
for granted that's that's just human
nature I try to what did I
Coke I try to keep perspective like oh
you know I'll talk to my therapist I'll
just reflect on all the good things that
are going on in my life gratitude will
do it yeah it makes you cuz you lose
appreciation like naturally human nature
is to just start taking things for
granted um friendships you know
relationships uh wealth automobile house
like you just start health I mean
everyone almost everyone takes their
health for granted right until they're
not healthy so it's hard to just sit
back and and reflect in the morning wow
I'm healthy I'm going to have a great
healthy day today I can go to the gym I
can go running um you just don't you
just live your life and you just you're
you're healthy and you take it for
granted you take your friendships for
granted I take bread for granted I take
wealth for granted I take my success for
granted I take the net show for granted
everyone genuinely starts the more you
understand that the more you I think you
can understand the concept of happiness
because and I'll give you a quick
example when we got a house in the Hills
our dad like bought it we were able to
move there when we were in law school
and I remember it was like my dream I
was ridiculous I was living in a
one-bedroom apartment and I remember
getting up to this house and I was
standing on the balcony with the views
and I was like holy [__] and then I
looked up and it was like a bigger house
it true story it was like a bigger house
like three blocks up I was like holy
[__] that's the house it lasted like 30
seconds you know and so if you realize
that if you're because people are always
thinking if this then this then I'll be
happy then I'll be no you'll have then
you always just want more and you have a
new persp that's not the way happiness
Works which means you might as well look
at what you have now and be happy
because I can promise you it doesn't
scale the way you think you know what
what how there's actually a particular
moment of of Our Lives where I think
this perspective hit me Brett and I were
traveling we were in Egypt um we were
behind the pyramids like a mile behind
the pyramids it was just like sand and
there were like you know 12 or 15 kids
um barefoot running around like the 110°
sand playing soccer with like little
makeshift goals and a soccer ball that
had like more duct tape you know than
any it was basically a duct tape ball
and they were laughing and having so
much fun and we jumped in the game we
played for like an hour and a half uh
with these kids it was so much fun and I
just saw they're smiling so much and
they're laughing so much and I just and
I'm like these kids are like happier
than I am they're you know probably
living you know on a dollar a day
playing playing with a a duct taped
soccer ball on 150° heat you know with
with no shoes on and they're as happy as
can be that's perspective I mean that
that moment in our lives I have a photo
of it with us all these kids um that
just I think taught me that perspective
is everything that's what creates
happiness's perspective you there's
American kids playing on a perfect field
with a perfect ball and like their
structured their uniforms and they're
mad at their mom because they're they
didn't get the cool cleats that they
wanted you know what I mean it's like
everything is is perspective in life but
human nature is to lose perspective so
knowing that you're not going to fight
it because human nature is you're never
going to wake up every morning be like
oh my God I'm grateful for this and this
you know I mean you can try it but it's
not going to happen so if you realize
that then what you are really realizing
is all these goals of like wealth and
happiness and and if I get this and this
and it doesn't work out that way life
never works out that way so if that's
the case embrace it and just realize
okay I might as well be happy with what
I have now because I'm realizing that if
I have a bigger house that's not going
to necessarily increase my happiness I'm
just going to want then a bigger house
so chill out and just be happy with what
you have and want more that's human
nature but don't think that it's
necessarily don't always have that
mentality I think you talked about late
earlier where it's like I'm going to be
super happy when I when I achieve this
it never works out that way I think
those perspective checks are incredibly
important I had one cuz I was thinking
about it since you said it in an
interview and it was kind of like in my
subconscious just kind of like
marinating there and then last night I
went to this party and they gave you
these wristbands and the wristbands have
this adhesive where you wrap it around
and stick it to the other side and when
the lady put it on my hand it just went
all over my arm hair maybe 5% of the
adhesive actually went on a tap you guys
know you know what I'm talking about
wristbands last night the same it's like
she tried I always bend it over right
you have more arm hair so yeah no I mean
it's like she tried to cause me as much
pain as possible and she did it and I
looked at it I'm like you got to be
kidding me and I'm looking around I'm
like well this is a pretty cool party
and they have an open bar and there's a
bunch of people here I'm excited to talk
to and then I forgot about the wristband
but I let myself sit with it for like 15
seconds of like this is so stupid why
would she do this how would she so bad
at her job and then I go and I have an
amazing night I wake up the next morning
and I feel a tugging on my wrist and I
look and there's just like all of my arm
hair is just wrapped up in this thing
and then I just go and I rip it out get
a bunch of arm hair with it and I'm like
that is so silly that I even cared about
that at all especially when I was
ripping it off of my you know my arm
it's like it there are so many real
actual problems that people face on a
daily basis and you said in this
interview you're like I don't have real
problems and I have never thought about
it like that like I don't have a serious
health problem I can afford a roof over
my head I can afford to feed myself my
family my immediate family everyone's
healthy everyone's fine I don't have
real problems and to admit that to
yourself and to admit that to all of the
people watching here is a very gutsy
thing to do because when you have
problems people they res honestly kind
of like respect you they see you as more
when you have problems it's like really
especially now in society I think it's
one of the biggest things is you're
defined by your problems how much of a
victim you are on the scale is like how
good of a person you are and obviously
so much I I mean obviously I'm very
fortunate to say I don't have real
problems in the same way that you guys
say that you do not have real problems
but it's just such a dose of reality of
like okay I ripped out my arm hair who
cares who cares it really doesn't mean
much yeah yeah how do you keep
perspective like that oh it's super hard
I mean you have to you have to
consciously remind yourself of the good
things in your life to be appreciative I
mean it's it's actually work you got to
work at it otherwise you just take
everything for granted and then you just
realize you're not as happy what
problems would you say you have today I
know you say they're not real problems
but if you really think like today like
what problems are you are you
experiencing even though they might not
be real problems pretty bad
hangover that's a real issue right there
yeah the half of that
hamburger yeah cold hamburger and a
hangover bad fren fries really I was
going to say it is I I don't think I
have
any real problems I would imagine maybe
it's like the real estate market slowing
down the performance of the show maybe
opening up new
offices you know I just I used to let
things get to me um and I just don't
anymore like I'm
oddly really good at just not getting
frustrated these days um it's a skill
set that I've I think I've just you know
done really well at I think almost by
necessity I have so many problems you
know that could be stressful and I just
I just now I'm choosing not to let them
stress me out have you guys ever had a
health problem
or close family member with a health
problem yeah not nothing severe no and
if you ever I don't when I got back from
traveling I had like a year I don't know
people have much bigger health problems
than that but if you have any type of
Health threat that gives you the
perspective of of potentially losing
your health it g it puts your whole life
in perspective for the rest of your life
that's to me the only real problem
people can have is health
money is like unless if it's affecting
your health and if you literally can't
feed yourself but I think if you don't
have a health problem and there's no one
very close to you that has a health
problem you pretty much don't have
problems I love this quote I think about
it all the time well I should think
about it more honestly but it's you have
a 100 problems until you have a health
problem then you have one problem and I
think it's very true one thing that I
think we already hit on this but I think
it's still worth noting I feel like
whether it's in universities or I'm not
sure where it started but I this victim
mentality now I think makes people
unhappy you know because I think we're
teaching people rather than go solve a
problem it's just to victim you know to
feel like you're
viol it doesn't mean that you're not a
victim there are there are millions of
victims and and bad [__] happens all the
time and it doesn't mean you can't talk
about it doesn't mean that you can't
complain but then shut up and go fix it
you know what I mean like don't just sit
I think a lot of people like the uh
attention the attention that they get
from it or the support that they get
from go online says I a victim here's
what happened to me here's how bad the
situation is to get thousands of
comments or tens of thousands of using
oh you know we we stand by you a whole
victimization support structure out
there right now to
fix don't deny the problem I mean by no
means are there not significant problems
out there people are victims of those
circumstances but I just wish we had a
more mentality of like okay now pick
yourself up I agree F I think personal
responsibility needs to be taken to a
severe degree yes
can I give another um ramble of
a
time how many mice
died this is a right dude I'm like
insecure about this burger being all
over my mouth so hold on no I don't see
anything no uh you're pretty good you
got little something right there I
always get so much [__] in my teeth
sound so bad every time I had a meal
with her she would point out [__] that
was stuck in my teeth and I'm like is
getting stuck in my teeth more now that
I'm with you or was it always that way
and you're just the only person that
ever pointed it out and now I'm like
traumatized um this is actually a really
good study okay so and just to be clear
this is not to say that there aren't
millions of victims and the society
doesn't have a lot of issues but this is
an important study to understand as far
as like success in life so there was and
it's a famous study it's been replicated
it's not you know my opinion again so
there was like 15 people that got facial
scars put on their face um with makeup
have you heard this one y okay it's
incredible if it's really important for
people to understand so so they have
these facial scars that makeup artists
put on their face and say okay you're
going to go into an interview and we're
going to see you see how the interview
goes and I'm going to ask you if your
facial scars played a role in your
interview and the interviewers have no
idea what you know what's going on and
so these 15 people go into a room right
before the interview after they look at
the mirror and they see their scars they
go into another room and the makeup
artist just says oh I'm just going to
touch up these scars real quick right
before you walk into the interview space
and without these people knowing because
there's no mirrors in that room that
makeup artist is actually taking the
scars off so they go into the interview
with no scars but they think they have
massive facial scars and they get
interviewed and then they're they come
out of the interviews for for the job
interviews and they're asked by the
people they're running to study did your
scars play a role at all in this
interview
process I think there was 15 of the
people and like 10 or 11 of the people
said he couldn't stop or she couldn't
stop looking at my scars made explicit
comments I knew I wasn't going to get
the job right when I walked in like
comments like that you know just like
defeatist comments 11 or 12 of the 15
said things of that nature and I mean
some of them went as far as to say he
made explicit comments about my my scars
just you know just anyway then the
interview said look none of you had
scars when you were in those interviews
and it was such an Illuminating
defeatist
victimization um you know conclusion
that these people had been coming to and
it just shows so much about human
mentality if you go into a situation
thinking that you're a victim you're
going to be a victim and it doesn't mean
that some people don't have facial scars
because in I I mean metaphorically some
people are in a position where they're
going to walk into an interview and have
a problem but they you know then they
have to either probably work harder than
other people and there's a lot of people
that go into that interview thinking
they have these issues that really don't
and if you go in with the Deus mentality
you're not going to get that job no
matter what so I would just advise
people to go into that room thinking
that you don't have facial scars even if
you do and and and I'm not to say the
world is fair some people have you know
have hurdles they have to clear that
others don't and that's I'm not opining
on the absence of that in society
clearly there is if you want to succeed
in life you know that study shows a lot
understand that the implications of that
study if you want to succeed in life
yeah it's a difference between
overcoming versus complaining and right
now we are rewarding complaining and we
should be rewarding you know where do
you think that changed because I don't
remember 15 years ago rewarding
complaining me neither yeah I feel like
it's something that's happened 10 years
ago started in the last few years it's
it's it's gotten a lot worse who do you
think is supporting this message well
it's like it's it has to be institutions
or something right like it there there's
got to be a deeper thing going on than
just like there got to be something
missing that that has opened up
opportunities right there's got to be
some sort of
deficiency I think it's good intentions
I think it's good intentions that
started it I think it's good intentions
of bringing awareness to to people who
do have problems in society which is a
good intention to have I just think it's
gotten to a point now where it's where
it's making life worse for a lot of
people instead of better you know which
is really unfortunate because I think
the intentions were good because there's
a difference between exposing
uh problems and and then complaining
about them I mean I think exposing
problems and addressing problems is good
but I think that we need to instead of
just valuing you know victimization and
like supporting victimization we have to
and beyond that literally defining
people by their level of victimhood you
know it's almost
like I don't know it's almost like in
Reverse of what you might want to be
doing it is kind of odd it's like a
metal that you kind of like proudly wear
a lot of the times but then it gives it
could EAS give that person a feeling of
this is who I am I am a victim and I'm
going to see everything through that
victim lens I'm going to go into every
uh every conversation that I have with
another human being thinking that I have
a scar on my face and it's that's not a
good way to go through life even if you
do have a scar on your face and I'm
using that obviously metaphorically MH
and it can't be a good it can't be good
for happiness feeling like you're a
victim you know the thing you don't and
that yeah exactly you don't you can't
run over and hit that lever you know and
you're making excuses but when you
actually can run over and you can hit
that lever that's what makes you happy
so I think there's it's got to be
creating a you know dissatisfaction
among people to feel like they're
victims and again that's not to say
there aren't victims you know but it's
just to say like you you separate like
being aware of the systemic issues in
society and doing your absolute best to
to amarate those and then there is the
defining people by their level of
victimhood and giving them giving people
like a mentality of like an almost an
inability to overcome because there's
consumed with that victimhood those are
two different things and I think we
started in a good place and ended up
over here or using it as an excuse like
there's a you can raise awareness and
you can address an issue but you then
you can also use it as an excuse that's
where I think we're is the problem is
that people are using their victim as an
excuse rather than just getting up and
going and solving it if you had a child
with a disability you know um you could
either parent them by saying look you're
going to you're constantly saying you're
going to have these struggles you're
going to have you're not going to get
hired it's going to be 10 times harder
for you I I I'm feel so bad for you like
this is this is this is a really
horrible situation that you're in that's
one way to raise that kid and and you
can track that kid's progress through
life and another way to raise that kid
is you're going to have to work four
times as hard because you have this
disability and I'm going to give you the
confidence and I'm going to tell you
that you can overcome anything you want
and you rais the kid that way you want
to track those two people through life
and see who comes out with an you didn't
they do that they did the study like
that with orphans didn't they with the
the stuttering did you see this telling
about studies now thank you yeah we are
uh so they did this with orphans they
they found two groups of Orphans I think
this was in the 40s or 50s one had uh
severe stuttering and the others were
perfect speakers and they put half of
the perfect speakers in with the
stuttering group and half of the
stuttering people in with the perfect
speakers and so one group was told you
speak fine you speak great the other was
like you have a severe problem and they
found that the ones who spoke normally
but were put into the stuttering group
started developing stutters and they
could not speak as well versus the
stutterers were put in the normal group
the exact same treatment as uh all the
other normal kids and they started
speaking better so it was really the
environment that they that molded their
personality and they stuttering to that
I mean I think that's if there's one
thing I can point to as to I think how
we became successful it's that it was
instilled in Us by our parents When We
Were Young that we could achieve
anything we wanted to do and they didn't
just say that like they actually
convinced us that we could do whatever
we wanted that we would be great at what
everyone wanted so I think it's the
opposite of of victim mentality like
they just said no matter what you are
capable of doing whatever you want
you're going to be great at it if you
work hard enough was that how they were
raised
too it seems like both of them were
successful in their own right I don't
necessarily think so yeah I'm not sure
they got the same and you're right think
maybe I was minimizing a little bit of
that when I was saying that it was it's
in my bones which it is in my bones but
I do think there's a definitely a
nurture perspective and our parents did
raise us that way and I think that's how
you have to raise your kids no matter
what you
know level levels of obstacles that
they're going to have to overcome
because of one thing or another you have
to raise your kids with that mentality
because that's what breeds success and
happiness speaking of kids would you
guys want any kids nice transition yeah
probably uh I'd say if I had to guess in
my life i' say maybe it's 50/50 but it's
not going to be anytime soon 7030
against really I'm also 46 years old
right now don't even have a girlfriend
so I'm a little behind the curve on that
yeah but I could have I could have a kid
at 55 I don't care yeah then you're
going to be like a 75 I don't I'm 75o
gradu be running around like a
50-year-old when I'm 75 okay so you have
nine more years Max I could have a I I
know someone had to kid at 72 I'm not
saying it physically isn't there like
like dicey stuff biological stuff that
can happen to the kid if you have a kid
at like 7 I don't think from the the
male no no no that's not true your your
sperm you have a higher um likelihood of
autism and a lot of other things if
you're well whatever I would do it in it
would so it doesn't matter have you
frozen any sperm yeah I also froze like
10 years ago I did too yeah just because
I did actually hear that that um an
older man can have like a less healthy
SPO do they know but it's not as big of
an issue for women are born with all
their eggs so they actually age whereas
men produce semen every day but that's
do you do they know the long-term side
effects of like a frozen sperm kid I
don't think there I don't think there
are any there are none but how how long
has this existed cuz wouldn't the kid to
like go entire life eggs I think can get
damaged over time yeah Frozen didn't
they they they froze the uh fzed embryo
I think it was like 30 years and they
had yeah and they had a perfectly good
uh you know child perfectly healthy
normal that is but the child was
technically like you know 30 years old
by the time they were actually born
right they celebrated his 31th
birthday Benjamin that's a whole another
debate we could go I'm not going to go
down that road is that child 31 or one
he definitely 31 starts drinking at 10
like technically I'm 40 years old
actually actually Social
Security uh it's it's interesting
because a lot of people tell me who are
really successful they say oh if if I
could have had kids earlier I I wish I
had done that versus waiting later you
know I there's a lot of different
reasons why people have kids I have a
ton of purpose in my life so I don't
need a child to create purpose in my
life in fact I also am very happy and
very fulfilled a lot of people mentality
of like creating Legacy which we just
don't have it all it's like I mean what
so you're going to be in a I I don't
know it's like every every family dies
off everyone every name gets you know
taking out of the history books EV like
who who I don't I don't have I don't I'm
missing that we don't have like a need
for our name to live on you know like I
just a lot of people have I care when I
say don't want everyone's like what
about your last name what about your
business what like everything dies
everything decomposes over time like in
life every Everything do you think
that's depressing to think about though
that everything is just going to
disappear one day really happy that
makes me sad to think that like 100
years from now like just people won't
remember you I know it makes it makes it
seem like everything you do is very
insignificant yeah isn't that a cool
feel I think that's a cool feeling when
I look up at the stars it gives me that
that feeling perspective of like
literally this planet doesn't even
matter let alone my life it actually
makes me Happ take things less seriously
like you know the oh my gosh there's a
my there's a clip that came out today
from our show of like uh crelle and my
girlfriend at the time like having lunch
and and they were kind of you know they
were not getting along and it was
stressful for me but then I was like you
know what like I'm going to look back on
this in a year and it's not going to be
I'll laugh at it and you know what it's
been a few months and I'm already not
stressed about it uh everything is
insignificant I was so stressed out at
the time and I'm like you know what I
guarantee you in six months this will
not be important to me it never is
nothing is important to me six months
down the road nothing that I that I
think at the time is is worth being
stressed about yeah it was looking back
ever worth stressing about so now I just
don't stress I anybody who's stressed
out about anything just to look up at at
the stars depending on where you live
it's tough in La I mean that just it
sounds cheesy but it's like for me when
I look up at that it just gives you the
unbelievable understanding of the
insignificance of not only your life not
only the human race but planet Earth
this galaxy to the universe we are as
meaningless as you could possibly
imagine like no offense to anyone in
this room I don't care if you're like
the president your life is pathetically
meaningless to the universe and to me
that's actually like calming you know
this seems like a newer development
especially For You Jason because I feel
like 5 years ago you were very careful
to
curate the you know the the image that
you wanted out there and be very careful
with it and so uh maybe a clip like that
would have just like you would be making
phone calls be like who filmed this how
did this get out there what are the
people saying delete those comments like
what what changed the first year of
producing I got about that I would say
if I had to attribute it to one thing
I'd probably see I'd say therapy I
started sing a therapist like four five
four years ago maybe and I would say
within a year or two I I have a list in
my phone of like the things that I need
to work on um but some of the things on
that list just really made me stop
stressing like U and internalizing
things I mean I think a lot of anxiety
is internalization of other people's
actions yeah uh and that was it was such
a cliche thing that she told me like you
know other people's actions are a
reflection of them and not me and you
know don't sweat the small stuff and
everything is small like all these
really cliche things that you might even
find in a book but they hit me pretty
hard um and I started thinking about
those things every day like when I would
have a coffee I'd read my list and
within a couple years and continuing to
see her I really just stopped worrying
about stuff like I am probably at my
happiest right now because I have the
least amount of stress I have probably
more problems in my life right now than
I did 5 years ago and I am five times
less just do you have a list of things
just to internalize every day yeah can
you share some of those things that like
maybe share the things that other people
could learn from because I'm curious
what those are yeah I mean I should you
should get contact with the with the
therapist I would be I'd be more than
happy to but I remember it the part for
me that the reason I brought that up was
because I posted a listing on my
Instagram this is when the YouTube
channel was just taking off and I posted
a new listing on there I think it was
the marvista listing and someone
commented something like this is a
[__] cool listing or something
like that and you had seen that comment
yeah and you said Graham why do you have
vulgar unsophisticated people commenting
on your instagam could delete that coma
we don't want the you know the sell when
you started your uh when you started
YouTube up in the upstairs in the office
you were cussing I'm like I will not
have cussing if you're sitting in this
office you know on YouTube yeah but that
worked because then YouTube started
demonetizing uh vulgar videos profanity
they I cared a lot I L the first year we
were producing
we would argue with the producers like
nuts if they released The Boll of us we
were stress cases we were yelling at
everyone we were like so upset about
everything string about everything and
because we didn't you know and then now
we're just like just do what you want
you know whatever you know yeah I mean
the idea that they wanted me to like go
on a date in like season one I'm like oh
my God I would never go on a date I
would never put my relationship on
camera and now like you know every PE I
my whole relationship in the breakup is
all on camera like I just don't care
anymore does that bother you though to
either read the comments about it or
people speculating about it I am so
thick skinned I haven't I don't even
comments honestly and if I did read bad
comments I would just laugh them off I'm
just oddly thick skinned and I think
it's great for this for what we do
because you kind of if you don't have
thick skin you're going to have a
problem if you think about the type of
person that's like sitting in the room
commenting on someone's some character
in a reality show I mean it's not to say
that everybody does that is like a loser
but I mean but if you're taking the time
to go on my Instagram and talk sh about
my height or my
I say that doesn't say more about that
person than it does about you I don't
know what that's on my list like other
people's actions are a reflection of
them let's do this list uh well that's
probably my favorite one honestly oh my
gosh um don't be too hard on yourself
I'm I can be very hard on myself I'm
less hard on myself now okay like I
don't judge myself as harshly as I used
to and that keep makes me more happy
don't take things personally
um let's see don't let Brett get under
your skin be less judgmental and
validate him is that is that on there
did you ask
reflect must have been added really
Recon this morning reflect on how great
life is that's like part of the uh um
perspective perspective uh rein positive
reinforcement at the office don't
criticize mistakes make them teachable
moments I try to be a better boss I've
been working on that and honestly I have
be a positive personality and then I
have in parenthesis Nico and Zelda my
dogs are like the happiest people on the
planet they're amazing and I I like to
like just watch them but Zelda is like
I'm like why can't I be as happy as
Zelda she has she's so happy all she
does is run around on a floor all day
long you know eat twice a day and she's
the happiest creature on the planet so
that I mean how come I I can't be happy
but the the best well be be less serious
um and other people's actions are a
reflection of them not me that that one
honestly I would get so validate gram I
would get so reactive to people you know
like they and and it's people all have
their reasons for whatever you know
they're going through and you know their
their actions and not everyone's a a
good person or not everyone's at a good
moment in their life um and I would
internalize that stuff you know like and
now I just I realize that's not about me
like that's about you you're making a
comment uh a nasty comment on my
Instagram that is a reflection of you
you're probably not in a happy space
they just I don't internalize that
anymore no no happy person no confident
happy person makes consistent negative
comments about other people that is a
fact there is no confident happy person
making negative comments on Instagram at
other people that's a fact does it ever
translate uh to in person like do
negative people ever come in person 100%
the same people that would that would
rip you a new one on Instagram like just
take a picture with you if they see you
on the street you know yeah yeah but I
try to tell I try to tell um the women
that on the you know that because they
you know some people internalize stuff
more than others um that you know it's
really a reflection of them they're not
in a good space or they're jealous and
there's a lot of that out there and
rather than them you know sitting with
with those emotions they they'll lash
out and try to take other people down I
mean there's a I'd say if there's two
huge problems uh in society that I would
point out one is the victim mentality
that I think that we are almost
rewarding at this point um and the other
one is just a lot of unhappy insecure
people trying to tear other people down
like people love tearing people down
it's it's like a sickness I don't
understand that because you it props
yourself up when you're putting other
people down you
know morally patting yourself on the
back when you say this person one of
those are they're IST you know what I
mean but that comes from an insecurity
so listen at the end of the day
insecurity and a lack of confidence
probably causes 90% of the problems on
this planet if people were more secure
uh and more confident we would have
relationship problem any of the problems
we have bolster confidence and security
or it's tough I mean I think it's the
little things we were talking about
clean your room and go to the gym yeah
and a therapist I think that if it were
up to me everyone on the planet would
see a do you have the same therapists
well you don't really I don't need
therapy I'm pretty
I go like every few months now like I'm
you know uh you do I need it as much uh
I used to but after Co just over Zoom
mhm and do you go with specific things
you want to work on or is it that you go
it's just like it's just going to the
gym it really is just like going to the
gym and just hitting every muscle you
know that's that's how I actually that's
how why I make myself go cuz I'm like
this is the gym for my mind so inter
because I've seen a huge shift in
talking to you today about this than I
have like 5 years ago six years ago you
seem like a different person I'm I'm
happier I'm more relaxed for sure I'm
less I used to be so reactive well one I
used to like take things personally and
I would I would always had I had this
fairness bone in me so I always felt
like okay maybe someone trying to take
advantage of me and that would just get
me so upset and now I just don't care
anymore and I'm just so much happier I'm
probably getting taken advantage of just
as much I just don't care anymore that's
really interesting yeah whenever he
would describe cuz I I met you once or
twice briefly whenever he would describe
you to me and you as well like it would
well you were a little bit different the
way he would describe you good my um but
you it was always a very serious
undertone kind of stoic and and uh yeah
like this is very different mattered
five years ago to me everything mattered
you know no granted I was really driven
I was building my business but and I I'm
a very very detail oriented person um so
everything mattered to me you know are
we cool with me using the bathroom for
course of course and I've just let
things become not as important to me
yeah and I realized like the things I
thought were important just aren't and
then you said on an interview that if
you do anything you should do it to the
best of your ability you used to I mean
you said you wanted to be a mechanic I'm
sure you worked on your was it Camaro or
something like that all the time and
youd take 3 hours to wash your
cars when do you pick your battles of
when do per perfectly versus when not to
do it perfectly are you still this way
or is this new N I think almost I think
I on everything you do I think you
should have pride in it I mean now that
we're pointing at all of society's ills
I'd say a lack of pride is something
that I think people are very prideful
don't you think so uh not in a not in an
honest sense not in an like I think
they're prideful in in terms of like
don't injure their pride you know but I
don't know if they're prideful in their
acts like what they like I like
everything I do to be I feel like that's
ction of me so if I'm going to if I'm
going to watch someone's car and I'm
going to give them that car that car is
going to be perfect I just I want to
have pride in what I do no matter how
meaningless it is so in honestly like in
everything in my life I just do it great
you know I don't have ass anything
Graham described the difference in not
work ethic but I would say just general
productivity between you two is that you
will grind throughout the entire year he
says you will love to like work hard for
like a month or two and if it goes well
then you can take the rest of the year
off that's a bit extreme but yeah and
okay and then I asked gram I was like
well who do you think is happier or more
fulfilled and Graham guess what he said
me I said Brett oh really yeah Brett
seems more relaxed more Carefree I mean
obviously I think there's been a
substantial shift but I would say based
on the last 10 years oh you seem to be
more like work um focused on that Brett
is very like you know I don't want to
say Whimsical but very Carefree I get a
ton of purpose from work so for me that
makes me really happy um I probably have
it depends on your personality yeah I
need purpose in my life so I think you
know what it was Jack asked me whose
lifestyle would you want Brett's or
Jason's and I said Brett's oh yeah
that's an easy one Brett is I don't know
though I love depending on your
personality right I think it's a
personality I would go crazy if like
when we're chilling on the in NY notes
for like two weeks I'm just like having
the time he's like I got to get back you
know you know what I mean so get that it
depends on your personality it really
does I enjoy my life more and his life
would drive me nuts but you know it
could be vice versa yeah so yeah I think
it's individualistic I mean I just I
need a lot of I get a lot of
satisfaction from purpose and from drive
and from work um and success I I just
really enjoy that he doesn't need that
so much you know I don't know exactly
why I need that um but it makes me happy
but it's interesting you guys have had
such a similar upbringing but the values
when it comes to that and what drives
you are different to some extent true I
mean I think there's way more similar
and differences but there are certainly
some differences I don't know everything
is a nature versus nurture I don't
really know the answer to that one but I
would imagine I don't even know 5050 I
don't I don't know how we ended up there
but I just I just appreciate certain
things more than he does and he
appreciates certain things more than
than I do but I think overall we have a
lot of similarities where do you guys
think your faults are cuz like your own
personal Faults Are you insecure about
anything
or are you very secure and confident
very secure and confident but I think I
guess everybody has
some well definitely faults I would
imagine some
insecurities I don't know if I have any
insecurities though but I definitely
have faults there's got to be something
you're in you're insecure about having
stuff in your
teeth there's got to be something but I
don't think we have any deep seated like
structural debilitating insecurity
though you got me on and it's always
been that way or is it no I'd say that
as we get older you know I'm more sure
more confident uh I mean I think I was
always a pretty confident guy but I
would say that it was not as much of an
inner confidence when I was younger as
it is today you know there's like a more
of a Bravado confidence when you're
younger and more of like a uh relax for
you confidence now I got true or
confidence yeah um but you know faults
yeah I mean you know everyone has that
what would you say is a fault that
you're working on or something that you
you could be improving I work on my
faults I just just ignore them I accept
I accept them just suppress them and
push them down I'm aware of them and
then I embrace
them I was trying to get out of
answering that with a
joke okay it's says way up saying it
doesn't be false buted I want to say
that okay I I also want to talk about da
selfish I think dating publicly it's
selfishness you think I think I'm
selfish yeah
really okay cuz that that seems very
different than what you to do I think I
love my life so much I don't like
compromising
it manifests selfishness let's put it
that way I don't think I'm naturally
actually selfish but I think the manner
in which I live my life can be Loosely
defined as partially selfish because I
just do what I want to do when I want to
do it you know what's interesting we had
a podcast with Patrick B David who said
that great leaders had to be selfish and
it's better to have a selfish leader
because someone who's too compassionate
is going to take too much feedback
they're not going to have results I
would agree with that I don't think my
selfishness comes from my leadership
abilities I just think it's because I
love my life so much I don't like to
compromise and it makes me a little bit
difficult to deal with sometimes but you
know it's one of my wonderful faults I
want to know in dating okay because on
selling Sunset I'm guessing like the
viewer demographic is like women 80
plus% 80% 80 plus% women there's a lot
of boyfriends that get stuck watching no
we have 80% of our Instagram followers
are women but 80 that's not 55% because
a lot of them watch what I have so many
husbands and boyfriends coming out to me
oh my I watch with my girlfriend with my
husband I I would bet it's got to be
7030 70% women it might be I think he's
probably I would say 6040 we don't have
the demo on that I don't think the guys
are watching every episode like you know
their girlfriends or wives might be
they're like stuck watching it and they
kind of passively watching seeing it
it's on the air cuz every guy that comes
up says oh my God my girlfriend loves
your show can I take a photo I'm like
every time never like I love your yeah
yeah exactly they just don't want to
admit it so let me put some chaps to
yeah how when when you're going out
you're going out to a bar you're going
out to a club okay you're having a good
time maybe have a table or something
like that when you say you're good with
women can you maybe walk me through what
exactly you mean by that like does the
the women come up to you you go up to
the women well first of all I'd say
because of the show now it's probably
easier you know but we've always been
pretty good with women okay I think good
with women means
um confidence to approach them and then
the personality to like really engage
them make them laugh and then kind of
like and then I mean there's a it's a
pretty broad I'm like like such an
pretty broad skill set but I think it's
just part of like and indiff I think is
I got I got to say this I remember this
is like pre all the Netflix stuff but
Jason was always just like a Sant when
it comes to like speaking with women
like always like everyone that would
come to the office you just had this
charm about you that they also super but
this is the part where I found it funny
uh someone would walk by the front of
the office and you would either turn to
Eric or I like hey was she cute I
couldn't see it and have my glasses on
and and Eric would usually have the
better view he's said yeah she's cute
all right I'll be right back and you
would run out of the office remember
this and you and sometimes she she's all
the way down the block but you would
just be running after
you but sometimes you would come back
and they would be either with you or
you'd be like a she has a boyfriend or
no she's married or sometimes you just
have the number and you would just like
text her right there your but you would
just like run after people I've never
seen that before I think I did that at
least a couple times yeah but the
success ratio was high like it wasn't
like a 10% chance it seemed like very
like I we had a lot of confidence with
women which I think goes a long way I'm
also extremely direct and honest with
women and I think that's oddly um
abnormal um so I think they appreciate
that you know and I humor humor has a
lot to do with it like we're really
engaging and funny with with people but
with women in particular they women love
to laugh and you know so we don't take
ourselves too seriously if you're conf
and you're funny and you're and you're
honest like you're in you know and not
also like we're good boyfriends like
I've never I'm not disrespectful to a
woman in a relationship ever um you know
don't ever cheat don't you know I'm just
a thoughtful person I think okay so
let's say you're approaching this woman
on Sunset Boulevard you didn't you
couldn't tell if she was attractive or
not but someone said yeah she was
attractive okay and you're like okay it
was a little blurry for me you run out
you chase after come with a pickup line
right now I'm too hung over to think
about but we never use lines like people
ask us what L never once do I ever know
what I'm going to say
to I've heard about this and I actually
kind of like this philosophy that you
can have as much game as you want but
it's not as successful as just being
that guy as horrible and cliche as that
sounds like I feel like there's some
Merit to that you know what I mean yeah
we're not we never read a book about
picking up I don't you know I I don't I
literally don't believe in knowing what
you're going to say to a girl and tell
you are like within 2T of her like I'll
go up and like I have no idea what I'm
going to say right now you're just
beautiful and you walked by and I just
wanted to come and say hi um what's your
name I mean just something really honest
it doesn't matter it's all you have your
foot in the door that's it just get your
foot in the door and then figure it out
and also lean into your insecurity
you're leaning into the stupidity of it
like you don't always have to be like a
tough guy you know you could be you
could be this is the advice that I would
give somebody who's like oh yeah I know
but I'm like a nerd I wear glasses and
there's no way I'm why does why don't
you just go up to gr be like listen I'm
kind of a shy introverted nerd I can't
believe I'm doing but you are so
beautiful come on I mean it doesn't
matter lean into whoever you are like
just be you you know don't try to be
some like if you're a nerd don't try to
have some like spit some stupid baller
line you know what I mean up
man
insecure no business talking to you
right now cuz you're way hotter than me
but I can't help myself what's your name
you don't think that's going to work I
mean just be you L legit I've got have
to go like are you interested in short
bald guys and what do they say well I
mean it's just a it's disarming like
just any anything disarming and honest I
mean anything that's not a pickup line I
mean I would never don't be some like
douche that reads a book about pickup
lines just lean into whatever just you
got to just be yourself eventually
they're going to figure out who you are
right so what's the point of like lying
from the beginning do you ever get
nervous if you see someone that's
attractive like going up and talking to
that person or not always a little bit
nervous yeah it's a little bit but
you're like a psychopath if you like go
up to a hot girl and you have like
literally no nervousness at you know
what I
mean um so you just go up you get your
foot say whatever I'm just really trying
to understand this and you are not
fearful of being rejected at all no but
no not really I mean no because I mean
what what's the worst case scenario
you're not going to can you can you
bring up a scenario you're not going to
date her if you don't talk to her I'd be
more frustrated if I didn't talk to her
you know what I mean that would eat at
me far more than re can eat at me like
for hours she was super so was there
ever a time where you you showed up and
you're hung over something and you were
stumbling on your words and it just went
horribly oh I'm sure oh yeah does any
get like in your brain right now when
I'm saying this or you just throw it out
you don't even think about it oh my
memory sucks it happened to me yesterday
I was at the farmers market and I was
with a couple of my buddies and um and
there was two really beautiful women and
we were watching them walk around I was
like whatever and then we were walking
home and they were in the car sitting on
the sidewalk I'm like and my buddy was
like kept walking like I'm going to go
talk to these girls and I like go go
talk to him and like you know it went
fine but it didn't go great and and I
and I waddled back to the like how do I
go like you know and I knew I was going
to get [__] but I'm like whatever I
don't [__] care you know like who
cares I me it wasn't like a negative
interaction it was just like didn't I'm
not going to end up dating them do you
remember what you said when you walked
out to them and just initiate the
conversation was it the Vibes or was it
what you said I they gave me the
impression that they were like married
or just not interested in a guy hitting
on them it wasn't like they were
offended by me going to talk to him I
think they were actually kind of
appreciated the attention but I just got
the vibe of like this isn't going to
happen um but I know it doesn't like
bother me like in the in the slightest
and also I don't I'm not I'm not saying
that
some unattractive like you know just
nerdy whatever guy at the B just go to
the bar just start relentlessly hitting
on every Hawker like you know just ch I
mean have some respect for your for you
know for for don't don't just like try
to get one out of a hundred you know and
just like annoy the [__] out everybody
at the bar and be relentless like if I
get a clue that it's not I'll back up
I'm not one of those guys like no I'm
going to talk to her seven times until
she's creeped the [__] out you know like
I think guys should be respectful and
don't you don't hit on 30 girls a night
and and you don't creep on them or just
stare at them for 20 minutes and not
talk to them or if there's not a Vibe
then just back off you know but have the
balls if there's a girl in particular
you're interested in have the balls and
you definitely don't leave that bar
without talking to her that's kind of my
general I mean life is is about
probability you know so if you're
interested in meeting a woman then you
have to increase that probability um I
mean it's everything you I think feel
like you can map everything out on a
bell curve you know and if you got to
just if you want something to happen
then you just got to put yourself in a
position where that's more likely to
happen if you want to meet a girl then
go to coffee don't have coffee at home
go to a coffee shop I mean just that's
it's all statistics MH you did the same
thing with clients at open houses by the
way sometimes people would leave and you
wouldn't see them leave and I remember
you running out the same way that you
would see a girl walk by you'd run out
and talk to that client as they're like
driving away in their car you'd like
flag them down talk I don't have a ton
of Shame I'll just I'll just do whatever
and like again I mean if you if you're
going to have that lack of Shame like if
you're going to you know have that
confidence then be authentic like I
think if there's I'm trying to think
about when you said why we're good with
women I wouldn't use that term I would
say authenticity is probably confidence
and authenticity are two things that and
through confidence and authenticity
comes honesty and and uh you know a lot
of other things like women respect I I
think everything emanates from from
confidence I think everything kind of
almost in life emanates from confidence
like real confidence not like bravado
arrogance but like if you really believe
believe that you're just like you know a
good human being who deserves you know
to be happy essentially you're not going
to be negative and talking [__] to
people you're not going to lie to a girl
to try to sleep with her you're not like
from that Foundation comes a lot of
other positive attributes if you really
just have to have that Foundation I
would love if you can give Jack some
dating advice this
always I me you're welc this is the best
it's going to get what do you want
what's your situation what do you want
what do I want I mean okay so I'm open
to anything that's kind of where I'm at
uh I don't want to pige and hold myself
into a certain thing OB boys girls I
mean girls okay yeah I will pige and
hold myself into that Niche but uh yeah
I I I would obviously eventually I want
to find the person I do want to have a
lifelong partner I think that's a pretty
I would say objective thing for me which
would be good what's eventually um in a
year and like I mean I don't want to
rush into it right like I don't want to
you met her now if I met her
now I I would like more experience I
suppose before but who am I to deny you
know a a perfect lifelong mate so I told
Jack the person who he is at 25 is going
to be totally different at 30 yeah but
you can also 25 okay but you can grow
with them which the other thing too
which is interesting because everyone
when they're thinking about uh dating
advice or finding a significant other
they're thinking about those actions
like those direct actions of meeting the
person when I think it's interestingly I
think and maybe paradoxically I think
working on yourself makes you attract I
I think reason that we are good with
women or whatever want to put it is
because we're very secure and confident
when we're alone you know I mean if you
want to go out and and like meet a great
woman make sure that you're at home
alone and you're happy and you're
confident and you you know feel good
about yourself cuz then you project that
when you go out let's assume women can
like uh well I'm saying like but working
on that is probably more important than
working on let's let's break down what
you just said to be at home alone and
happy with yourself
what sort of metrics what more for women
like I think women make very bad
decisions often with men and it's not
because they're they're always like why
do I choose the wrong guy like that's
not they're not choosing the wrong guy
they're just not happy with themselves
and that's the problem so instead of f
they always focusing on why am I
choosing the wrong guy they're not
focusing on themselves and it's the same
thing with men too I mean I think you
just if you work on your from place of
SEC you're going to find a good person
remember when I said if you're if you're
I forget exactly how I phrase it but if
you have a foundation and Co confidence
and and happiness then you have gravity
for other good things you don't it's
exact opposite everything NE you'll go
to a bar and you will meet a a beautiful
and and that woman will be secure too
like you'll draw a secure intelligent
you know uh woman you are I do want to
dive deeper into what you said about
existing alone in your house and being
happy and confident and secure and all
that stuff so what metrics and what
other things do you use to determine
whether or not you're happy like like
what could be affecting that experience
that you just said that's a tough one
for me so if somebody if somebody's home
and they're not happy they're not stoked
what would you recommend they do oh
there could be a million different
things that are making them not happy I
mean I think you just so how do they
figure it out well we talked about this
just those little things of of a certain
control over your life you say it's
purpose get purpose go to the gym eat
well cleaning your environment going to
the gym there's only there's certain
things that everybody almost everybody
has well everybody first has a body so
assert control over that assert over
that second most the M vast majority of
people have uh a place where they they
you know a habitat assert control over
that take pride in that just start at
the absolute Basics if you have a job
even if you don't like it be the
employee the whatever you have control
over prideful of what you're doing
control over that and and have pride
over that and then things emanate from
that and also treating people really
well makes you feel good about yourself
so even though you're doing something
nice and you know it's supposed to be
altruistic it actually makes you feel a
lot better so one that's thing you can
control you can control the way that you
treat people and that gives you
confidence it makes you feel good work
be very prideful in everything you do
including your work and then take care
of your body take care of your health
you're if you're doing all those things
you're probably going to be a lot
happier I think a lot of that is not
being attached to a certain outcome like
if you're happy by yourself at home
you're not going to be too dependent on
this other person I think that's why
people make bad decisions because
they're they're they are seeking a boy
or a girl to make them fulfilled and if
that is the reason you're out there
you're going to pick up right you're not
a whole
yeah there's so many women that I know
that that are like why do I keep making
the same mistake with men I mean it is
definitely not that they're making bad
decisions is that they're looking to
fulfill something there's a few reasons
for that too there's a lot of women that
I know that that are dating athletes
there's also like it's like I want a
super sexy sophisticate like worldly
wealthy confident outgoing super funny
like huge personality I'm like that guy
is banging every girl in La you know I
mean like I'm not saying that that
doesn't sound like a great guy but for
God's sake maybe maybe date an
accountant you know who's like really
nice and like charming and and loyal and
and and generous and and a kind person
you know I mean like you are common
sense if you really want like a husband
don't freaking date the NBA player no
offense to all NBA players you know
that's like gregarious and like has
knows everybody and walks in the club
and just [__] with the bounc it's
like that guy is cool to be with but
seriously I mean use some [__] common
sense you know that guy's GNA cheat on
you and be an [__] I think it goes
the the other way too with guys that go
for women who just you know they're not
going to necessarily make the best wife
but you know they'll be attracted to
that yeah it it goes for both I I I
guess I see it a lot more in women
because I have this conversation a lot
more with women and if I'm talking women
are better at being uh monogamous too
generally you can find a very successful
gorgeous Confident Woman that is very
down to just be monogamous yeah
generally speaking even more so in La
like the very the really outgoing
confident successful good-look guy
probably is less inclined to be
monogamous you know it's just a
testosterone yeah do you think that's
just an options thing maybe in La more
options Disneyland for for thaty yeah I
mean I would argue that most Mar a lot
of marriages across this country um are
monogamous because of of default because
they're not presented options I mean if
you took those marriages and you put
them into like you know the middle of
West Hollywood for 5 years and you know
you had beautiful people around all them
they probably would have a less likely
chance of being together yeah but when
you never meet be when you don't see
beautiful women all day long it's a lot
easier to be monogamous at home I'm sure
is that one of the reasons why you've
decided maybe not to get married at this
point yeah I'm sure if I was in De Mo
Iowa my chance of being married would be
higher I don't think it would be Skyhigh
but it' be higher than being in West
Hollywood yeah there's no place I could
probably be to that would lower my
chances of marriage more than West
Hollywood yeah there was a divorce
lawyer who's making his rounds right now
on podcast uh I think James seon who's
incredible but he was saying something
that I think it was fewer than 20% of
marriages last and are actually happy
50% end in divorce and then about 30%
stayed together for the kids but they're
not happy I would say that track with
with my uhac I would have guessed maybe
10 to 15% yeah and we're and we're you
know we
analytical so you know you look at those
statistics and I'm not I know everyone
thinks they're not a statistic but you
by definition you are a statistic I I
would imagine marriage would be
considered
you guys are homies and then part open
relationship multiple Sol everyone's
going to figure out their own solution
but do you think that that would be
productive do you think that that is a
good way to well given what Graham just
said do you think that's productive with
the statistics Graham just said 20% of
people happy I would say I mean the B
how can you but how can you get that
number just strictly off of the the
relationships and stuff like that sorry
the 20% of people or 20 happy in
marriage well you're saying productive
but the think it's good for society that
people are not taking a traditional well
happiness is better for society I think
there more people that are happy that I
mean I'm a utilitarian so I think
overall happiness is the moral goal and
if you have a lot and I think this is
true a lot of marriages that are unhappy
that cannot be good I mean as like the
majority how is that how is that
sustainable but what about back in the
day I mean they also weren't happy back
in the day yeah but they it likes to Eng
Grand eyes like the olden days you know
like they different cult go back to the
30s 40s
50s they were they you got married and
you never got divorce but 80% of them
were unhappy that's not marriage I think
started with with for financial reasons
it didn't start from love religion I
think you kind of do need some sort of
like lifelong partnership to like Foster
a good productive Society with family
units and stuff I I think that's a good
thing if it's happy what if 80% of them
are unhappy then I think it's more of a
personal thing than it is probably a
familiar thing maybe people are getting
together for the wrong reasons we've
tried marriage for over 100 but you have
better structures I don't think people
get together for the wrong Reas I think
people stay together for the wrong
reasons and that's why they're unhappy
okay I might be able to get but I mean
if if you have a system like that's
that's been failing for Generations
whether it's like you know Public
Schools or or the institution of
marriage what's the solution I just
don't know if it has been feeling maybe
I could be living in like a little
bubble and I'm not referencing I'm not
refc sure static let's assume those
statistics are true though just for the
purpose of argument sure that 80% of
people are in marriages are not happy
50% end of divorce I think it's higher
than that and 30% of the remaining 50%
are unhappy So 20% of people are pretty
sustainably happy when you get M you
have a one in five chance I would say
statistically being of actually living
with that yeah that being your one soul
anous mate that you're happy with for
purpose of this argument let's just
assume that's true so we don't fight the
right what other institution would
survive with 20% success rate it's
difficult though because I went through
and I looked up all of these statistics
about like you know what couples are
least likely to get divorced and it does
go down to about 25% if you're over the
age of 25 college educated and make a
certain amount of money well I
think waiting to get married is probably
is because I think that marriage is a
great institution um but I think that
it's just it's rushed into I think that
people should my dad got married last
week at 75 I think people should be
getting married later you know well
maybe maybe it could survive with with
different um like I mean I have no stake
in this game I all things being equal I
kind of hope it survives but if I had to
bet on it I don't know but maybe uh
maybe you do I don't know maybe there's
a solution where you try to encourage
people to do it later but what are you
going to do say be wealthier and be
educated and be older I mean that you
can't force that on a societ make more
money what kind of how would the kids be
raised in this sort of like thing that
we're we're describing that I mean I
have hold on real
quick we've already said that 50% of
kids are being raised by a single parent
already in this in this structure that
it is right now MH and 30 that's it's
but I don't an additional 30% are being
raised by a what is the data on on these
kids that are being raised up in single
parent households when probably not as
good as I know I'm just giving you this
stats cuz you're ask because you're the
way you phrase that question made it
sound like everybody's being raised by
married couples 50% of kids are being
raised by single parents according to
this if we're if we're agreeing with
this stat another 30% of kids are being
raised by a couple that aren't happy
with each other
so that the the question itself you know
kind of cheats the the issues but 80% of
kids are already in a bad spot well one
I think people probably have there'll be
less kids which I think is probably a
good thing it's like we need population
um so I think people are being more
careful about the decision to have kids
and the decision to get married I think
those are both healthy I think that it's
there's not a mandate anymore that you
have to have a kid to be like a
successful person that used to be a man
you know basically mandate for last 100
years fertility rates are plummeting in
developed countries absolutely
plummeting but I think the main risk to
society is not global warming it's it's
fertility rates and it's a guaranteed
that we're going to die out essentially
guaranteed unless we change something
dramatically that we're just going to
die out as a population if you look at
China and Japan and South Korea and the
United States every every single country
in the world has fertility rate below
two Yes except for some of the countries
in Africa the entire world only two is
sustainable because there's a I think
right now man and a woman having a need
every couple the average
is 1.7 yeah and and the wealthier the
country the more developed the country
the lower the fertility rate like a
direct relationship with that so if it
wasn't for Africa who will eventually
get developed enough to have less than
two fertility rate that's if you really
want to talk about threats existential
threats to society that's number one two
3 four five and six is think about less
kids is it just because they have more
options they don't need societ almost
mandated that you have a kid or you were
you were weird now it's it's become
normalized to not have a the wealthier
more intelligent you are I don't exactly
know why but this is just a fact the
wealthier more intelligent more
developed Society you live in the less
kids you have I mean that is a fact
throughout the world that's not I mean
we example I don't exactly know why you
know 50 years ago you would have a kid
already you would May would have a kid
You' have six but now you don't because
used have six you can be 40 and not have
a kid and it's normalized but we're
pivoting that that is an interesting
thing to talk about but we're pivoting
from uh from marriage so let me ask you
well that's also been normalized too
open relationships fluid relationships
you know whatever type of non-
monogamous situation those are
normalized now and my guess is in 52 100
years it will be probably even the
dominant Rel stat do you think that
that's moving in the right direction for
society or do you feel like it's better
to have more of a constrained uh well I
don't think constraint is a good thing
in of itself I don't think you know
defined constraints are good I think
happiness is good sure so if the and I
don't know if there's enough studies on
these relationships but if we look in 50
years and people are happier and in
happier relationships then I think by
definition um those structures are are
better than the current system believe
in choice and being open-minded I I
don't know the solution I just know that
I don't see a solution right now unhappy
marriages is not cannot be the answer
and there are too many people in unhappy
marriages I mean if I so you might as
well try meet another guy who tells me
not to get married I mean that's the
whole concept of Federalism is try have
the states be the Laboratories of I
forget what the exact term is of of
experimentation try different things in
different states as opposed to forcing
one thing on the on on all of the United
States and that's kind of the beauty of
of our Federalist system so with
marriage why don't we tried tons of
different types of relationships see
what works for some people some works
for other people there's no way there's
going to be one solution for everybody
because people are so different and I
don't know the answer I just I know that
I don't see an answer right now and you
think that you're going to be the 20% as
does everybody else who gets married but
you have an 80% chance I guess you're
wealthy and educated and and over 25 so
maybe you have a 50% chance whatever it
is but the institution's already changed
too it used to be you couldn't have
interracial marriages you couldn't have
gay marriages so it's we've already
finally normalizing different types of
relationships and that's obviously a
positive you know what I mean um so I
think it's just going to continue yeah I
mean what was interesting is that we we
spoke with someone recently um was
talking about arranged marriages and how
those were actually the happiest overall
they had the most fulfillment they were
the happiest and they stayed together
the longest yeah maybe it's the exact
opposite of us being
West interesting uh uh studies as well
because people are happier with their
decision when they don't have a choice
yes that's been proven in studies so
which is why people are less like you
give somebody 20 options at a restaurant
let's say or 30 options at a restaurant
or whatever it is they'll generally be
less happy with their choice of food
than if you give them four options um if
you give somebody is the so if you give
somebody one option and you tell them
like this is your wife and you don't
think that you have any other option you
probably actually psychologically will
be happier with that person because you
don't have any other options and you
know don't if you're looking around
you're like oh I couldn't married that
person I couldn't married that person
you're probably going to be less happy
that's why all all weddings give you
three choices on the and I'm kid but I
have heard that that's uh the studies
show that three options is is that's why
marriages are probably don't last as
well in I like that's why basking
Robbins is not many options but I want
to get back to you dating so you think
that this is I mean maybe it will work
for you but I know it will work for me
and I know by definition I am part of a
statistic or whatever but I'm very
confident in the same way that you have
confidence in every way every decision
you walk through life with I have a lot
of confidence in this one so you're
looking for that now or or you just know
you want like I said I I don't I I mean
I'm looking for anything I like I'm I've
openness to experience right are you not
out there dating like what are you doing
yeah I am dating yeah okay yeah don't
get defensive calm down bro we get
it settle that yeah I know I'm totally
daed a ton of people too they're really
hot okay so why would you need advice
like what's wrong with well I I don't
think I do the thing is like I I've
received a lot of advice over the course
of the past couple of years years
specifically from Graham from other
people select people as well it's funny
I don't and it's good it's been very
productive for me and I think that I'm
finally at the point obviously I'll
continue learning I'll continue getting
experience and stuff like that but I
think I'm I'm pretty I think I've kind
of good I would then I don't have any
advice for you thank keep being you bro
all right I'll try there got to be
something you could ask of course there
are things I can work on um the main
thing I suppose that I have but I don't
think that there's anything that you
could necessarily say hopefully you can
uh to solve this would be the fear of
rejection
and then there's also one other thing
when you talk to somebody in a friendly
manner but you have romantic interest in
them for me it's very hard to break
through that barrier of platonic to
nonplatonic I don't know how to
necessarily navigate that transition
that is the one thing that's always been
very tricky for me the other thing is
the fear of rejection if I could solve
this is noral and if you got rid of fear
of rejection you'd be a those two things
are related right but but but people
conquer it right so it's of course it's
normal I you can minimize it um but
again those two things are related
if you internalize rection there's with
you then I won't you as much you know
there's a milon reasons one of the
supporting Frameworks that you have that
allow yeah if you take things personally
you know or internalize uh other
people's actions then you're going to be
sensitive to rejection uh that's not but
there does have to be a certain thing
where you need a reality check of like
okay well I've asked out 100 girls in a
certain Manner and they've all rejected
there's no guy that I think gets
rejected and and like it doesn't right
it can sometimes be a reflection of you
right some like we got to
beor you're right it be reflection you
know if there's a pattern generally a
reflection of circumstan women are far
more open uh than men are I think
physically you know women I think are
find um personality you know safy
security like so many things as more
important um men I think are much more
superficial in I think I think men take
it as a reflection of their looks and or
their lack of money when it's really
reflection of lack of confidence I think
that or just a bad personality could be
that too could
be always say I didn't get that girl cuz
she cuz she wants a guy with more money
and she wants a six foot dark hair with
no dude you're either douche or you're
insecure you know it's a personality and
then it leads guys to like front you
know and that's the worst thing you can
do is not be yourself not be authentic
people see right through that that's the
thing it can take eventually they do
yeah eventually they will no I think
that's good so so you would say to
somehow Eclipse that
platonic to
nonplatonic oh that's a I mean that's a
very is this like a friend you've had no
this is just like like like you're
talking to somebody and and I would say
gauging interest maybe not even platonic
to nonplatonic but like gauging interest
you're talking to someone casually in a
bar right and then like you're kind of
waiting for a we light I'm not the type
to be like okay like am I good am I not
good like I'll just kind of stand there
and just be like this and then like I
was Jack and she'll like brush my arm
and I'm like that seems like like 5% me
say Jack in it he can't see it there's
so many times where I tell Jack dude
that girl was into you no no she wasn't
into me I'm like dude I could I could
see it she was no no she wasn't and then
plenty of times too where he's like d
I'm really into this girl I'm like she's
not into you at all and I could see just
by the messages I mean this is like a
friend it's not going any I don't think
you have a great gauge on that I do
every time no you have not been right
every time gra you are so wrong you
cannot remember the dinner one you were
going to go that's one specific one yeah
because it was the most recent it was
like two weeks ago which dinner one was
like two weeks
ago there's also some Nuance to that but
we can we can work around that yeah
there are some new nuances to that
anyways he's not right all the time and
he's been wrong actually a lot can are
better with SE move of course I agree I
do agree with that but I will say he's
dis surprisingly
wrong what what's the risk of just
trying to take it plas bonic every time
what's the risk just denial I mean
what's the risk of just asking if you
don't know if she's interesting just ask
for her number what's what if she sees
you as a friend it's like how do you
deter I can't read before you let's go
to dinner so what okay but I'm thinking
like more straightforward like hey are
you into me but you got to do it way
that's desperate that's yeah you winced
when I said it you why why you do it way
before you're you're friend with this
person like that takes like a month but
do it on the first date see what'll
happen Jack will ask for a number she'll
say yes he'll say let's grab dinner
she'll say yes and then over dinner
she'll be like oh so I'm thinking of
starting a YouTube channel and this and
it's just it's platonic there's nothing
rantic there that's not what happened
where are you getting that information
from there been a few times you told me
hyp that could that that happens to me
sometimes or like I'm looking at in real
estate and I'm like okay maybe this is
not you know happens that happens don't
okay I'm sure I'm sure it does happen
never to me though always like to me it
doesn't happen to me as often as it
happens to you I'm just saying it
happens probably happens to you a lot
right oh all the time every single day
basically yeah but no it's it's actually
it's not too tough out there at at a
given time it kind of was tricky it's
can be fun out there I mean people
complain but I think it's fun I agree
there's a lot of good people out there
by the way I do not believe in a Mr
Right and a Mrs Right There are probably
50,000 or 100,000 Mr rights and Mrs
rights for every person you don't meet
your soulmate you have there's a
probably a million soulmates for you out
there so it's not that hard well I do
think obviously that there is one person
out there that you are most compatible
with but there is
a statistic you Mar you're not going to
find you were to live years single you
know thailander possibly yeah more
densely populated areas right no I'm
just saying there's one person a scale
you L up out of 8 billion the chance of
that person being in LA and ever come
into contact with luy to get someone in
the top 400,000 right I agree but I I I
think and you're prob nobody on the
planet is with their soulmate
statistically nobody is with soul St
there's always
one billion people that means there 4
billion potential partners that is if
they were to marry every single person
no there's there's 8 billion potential
partner she date babies through 8y olds
okay so we
that's true I me but there's probably
you know 300 million potential Partners
sure okay I what I'm trying to say is I
think you're probably in agreement with
this I've always thought that there's a
threshold of compatibility if you exceed
this threshold with some other person
then you are viable lifelong partners
with them but you can obviously go
higher and higher and higher and higher
on this like range of compatibility but
as long as you're over the threshold
you're okay now I don't want to hold out
for someone that's just over the
threshold you know what I'm saying like
I want to try to find someone that's not
only over the threshold but like as high
as I can Poss
says everybody who's ever gotten a
relationship but I agree there's no Mr
and M and by the way so the more
confident you are when you're at home
alone watching Netflix you know doing
your thing the more the less you're
going to settle and that so therefore
the the better spouse you're going to
choose so if you really need a
girlfriend you're not and you're
insecure and you're not happy with
yourself you're going to just as soon as
you hit the threshold you get a seven
you're you're going to lock down but if
you're super confident in yourself so
you don't you're not trying to to
fulfill something with a relationship
then you're going to say you know what s
down until I get a nine right and then
guess what you get you end up getting a
nine might take longer so I think those
relation being bat [__] crazy I don't n
in terms of looks n in terms of like
threshold overall nine yeah yeah so if
you found somebody in like the the top
one percentile I have many times I say
every girlfriend that I've had is top
one percentile doesn't mean that I'm
going to get married but I you know I
don't think there's anything wrong when
do you disqualify people in dates what
does it require I mean we could have a
dating say you know like well there's a
scale if you're super
high it depends where my are you have
aart to Crazy
SK there are other YouTube videos on
this you don't need me for that someone
someone said I think it was Ty Lopez
actually we had him on the podcast
recently he asked what I was interested
in women and I said like number one I
said intelligent he said yes well there
are actually plenty of studies that
exist that say that like you're most
compatible with people that are in one
standard deviation of your IQ which I
thought was really interesting so like
it you can't just say you're in
attracted to intelligent people because
if you're intelligent by by the St if
you are very intelligent you're going to
need an intellect and if you're an Elon
Musk I mean you can't just be you know
you have to group like from very select
gr there may be nobody who can satisfy
intellectual you know Curiosities yeah
but I don't think that you I mean that's
one category yeah I think there's a
range of intelligence that I would be
willing to be with long term from like a
six to a 10 on intelligence scale
depending on where she is every other on
everything it would be the same thing
for overall happiness like I like a
happy person um a confident person a
beautiful person funny you take too
seriously yeah respectful you can be you
can be better you can be super smart and
[__] in conversation and vice versa so
there's so many categories everyone s
has to sacrifice you're not going to be
all those things sex life I mean there's
so like if she's a 10 in bed and a six
on intelligence I'd rather that than a
10 in intelligence and a six in bed I
don't know think but but either way
Maybe not maybe not everything's a you
know
that's a tough one that's a really
there's a lot of
diagrams I have to figure it all that
but you know everything got be a
flowchart and there's so many different
categories of of characteristics that
you got to consider so I mean you know
right it depends what you want in life
too are you just looking for sex are you
looking for marriage are you looking for
kids so you know parenting skills
maternal instincts that's huge if you're
looking for a mom you know so I mean it
depends on what you're looking for
that's interesting that you don't plays
very much importance on that uh yeah I
don't you know I don't because well he
needs to be mothered so I would that I
would definitely look into that like I
would think okay how was this person
raised by their parents because
realistically it's probably going to be
something akin to that right how we
would
ra Jud have [__] childhood a great mom
but yeah yeah so your skills your your
list of characteristics is different
than ours right you know right of course
and Graham yours I'm sure is different
from ours as well I'm just trying to
Loop him into the conversation I'm just
actively listening I thought so he loves
to like when in any l in the convers he
just like directs all conversations
towards me and dating what are you
finding today in the real estate market
it was interesting it was two and a half
years ago by the way you made a
prediction that you said that home
prices would remain high and that
inventory would be really low because no
one would want to sell when interest
rates go up and you film that with us
when interest rates I think were about
3% before they started hiking rates the
one thing you did get wrong was that you
said that homes above 5 million would
not be affected because a lot of those
buyers are cash and they don't care and
you said the hardest hit properties
would probably be in the one to three
range CU that's where they're very
interest rate sensitive it seems like
now the 1 to three range is holding up
whereas the over five is really taking a
hit because those buyers are pulling
back you mean in terms of volume or
prices prices I'd say say that's right
with everything you just said yeah well
but I'd say that that the lower I mean
everything has taken probably down about
10 or 15% from the high but I'd rather
be selling a $ 1.5 million house right
now than a $15 million I mean obviously
for the commission I'd rather to yeah
but I think that's always the case I
mean I don't think there's ever been a
time where you rather but I think the
highend ultra high end has gotten hit
harder than the low end which is well
the man the Mansion tax I think really
hurt the high that was not predictable
um i' would say outside the Mansion tax
we'd we'd be seeing a much healthier and
robust uh transaction volume not
anywhere near what we were used to but
like Nationwide I think the volume in
most cities for uh luxury has dropped
about 25 to 35% and I think in La where
at about 60% and I think that has to do
with the Mansion T what do you think is
going to happen over the next two to
five years just
overall around in La then um we're never
going to see a return to the robust
consequen of the highend market or
development development shut basically
shut down what about around the country
not necessarily just LA but just in
general for someone watching this they
want to know your ins I think interestes
are going to come down probably in
within you know 12 days8 to 12 months
I'd say it's a little sooner maybe and I
think I think macroeconomic we're pretty
sound we really are I think this is
really an interest rate driven issue um
that's not true of like office space and
some retail because after coid and
cultural shifts are going to remain in
in effect maybe forever for generations
and I wouldn't want to be anywhere near
that sector but for residential I feel
like macroeconomic Trends are strong the
only issues really is real estate I mean
pardon me is interest rates and I think
yeah I'd say 12 to 18 months I mean look
i crystal ball about 12 to 18 months
interest rates will probably come down
and I think that will have to around 5%
I'm guess a linear
you know reaction with I mean we're not
going to go back to 2021 you know in
terms of that nor should we I mean that
was just too in terms of what interest
rates or in terms of volume and Sal
everything so in terms of interest rates
we're not I mean I hope we don't go back
below 3% that's just that's not
sustainable it creates too much growth
um and too much speculation and um and I
also don't think we're going to see that
type of of sales volume that we saw in
2021 we're not going to see that type of
price increase I mean 2021 was an
anomaly I hope that we don't see like
four to 5% interest rates on a 30-year
loan under five would be great
sustainable healthy enough you know and
I think the market will I think I think
it was core logic that said 4 and a
half% would be the Tipping Point that
the majority of people who have a rate
locked in at 2 and a half to 3 and a
half% would consider selling at 4 and a
half% anything above that would pres
would cause them to stay yeah yeah I
mean I don't know if there's any
particular but I'd say about four four
and a half would be fine it's all a
sliding skill as IND go down you're
going to see more volume um and
development you can't develop right now
because you know construction loans are
just too expensive so between I mean La
specifically is going to have a really
hard time with yeah but I mean his we're
talking about nationally what's your
advice to someone who's thinking about
buying a house right now is it to wait
uh no well I would probably if I were
looking to buy I'd probably wait three
to six months and and try to pick up but
if you find the right house and you can
truly afford it yeah but I would also
negotiate if I was a buyer I'd be I'd be
writing a low offer right now try to get
next year's pricing today I mean I think
that if things soften you want to bake
that in uh I wouldn't buy right now
unless I wouldn't stretch right now a
deal if I could really afford something
and I had a partner we we needed a place
to live and we were whatever like
depending on your situation you find a
great house you negotiate the you
negotiate it hard your finances are
reflective of being able to hold that
house for the next 10 years pretty much
no matter what happens there's no reason
not to buy but if you you know are
stretching and you're like single and
you're just like I have to get real
estate and I I can get this you know
house if I if I don't if I get a
shittier car and if I don't eat out for
dinners if I can hold this like just
chill for a little bit buy and like you
know wait for things to play out the
issue that I see is when you look at the
the price to buy versus rent renting is
half the the cost right now yeah renting
probably makes more sense than than
buying but not in the long term you know
so I don't know if it makes sense it's
to rent for one year if you really want
to buy a house you might as well just I
think the break even when I did the math
on this was about 10 to 12 years where
becomes Break Even between the
difference between buying and renting
when you account for closing costs
maintenance well that's what it is right
now though with interest rates factor
for appreciation uh net 1% over the next
10 years because I'm counting for
maintenance and random things going up
in price like your insurance going up in
in price property taxes going what did
you account for property appreciation
before you Ned everything 2% 2% average
annual that's low that's low over the
next 10 years from today I don't
necessarily think
come on statistically I don't think I
don't think it's going to be low when
you look when you look at over 100 years
stally if you look over 100
years no it depends on the area but then
you also have to take into account area
uh inflation after inflation small town
in Texas maybe but what are we talking
you're telling me that a million dollar
house in 10 years is going to be worth
1.28 million possibly in a major city
where we talking about uh no just just
overall I'm talking about like a
national that's lower than Cisco know if
there's been a 10year span where real
estate is I'm sure there has but
statistically that's low that's all I
think when you adjust for inflation I
think that number might well now we're
talking that could be below infl that
that that could be high if we're for
inflation but that's not fair because
rents will go up over 10 years according
to inflation yeah that that will track
the same potentially but rents are
falling right rents are falling right
now I because I think gener track prices
are falling everyone who's locked in
that 2 and a half% mortgage is going to
want to sell it and so if interest rates
stay high everyone's going to turn into
going to start R but that's not a that's
a that's a two-year problem that's not a
10 year problem I could I could see that
being a three to six year problem a lot
of rates should still be high in three
years possibly if they remain at 5% yeah
five because the other thing is you're
not getting a a 30e fixed anymore so a
sevene like two years ago a 3% was
actually 3% because everyone was getting
a 30-y year um now a three you know a 7%
is really a 6% because no one's getting
a a two Nuance we can agree there
shouldn't be any fomo right now if you
can't truly afford something in the long
term hold it for at least 10 years and
it's a great property and you think
you're getting a great priz buy it other
other than that like there should be no
rush right now can we just all agree on
that yeah all right thank you so much
really appreciate that thank you Jason
uh for coming on the show I'm so glad to
make this happen and and one thing I
obviously I kind of have like this like
pseudo relationship with you guys
because I know you by proxy via gram um
so I feel feel like I I know you guys
and I feel like you have been a distant
mentor of mine you know my mentor yeah a
lot of the advice you and Jason give me
I pass giv it right back I wasn't aware
of that that's that's nice so it's
actually helped quite a bit so I
appreciate that even though I've never
really met you but pleas for all the
help totally my pleasure jumping on this
I love that what you guys are doing love
my brother and I both are fans of the
podcast and you guys personally it's
it's fun to jump on here so you should
be doing this more often cuz you're so
good speaking and like maybe you don't
have an interest in it I don't have an
interest in it reason I do it is because
of our personal relationships um but
you're right maybe I should do it more
often maybe this will encourage me and
you give one shout out you give one
shout out for the episode to like what
do you mean whatever you want to say to
the audience you could tell them watch
selling Sunset you could tell him to you
know check out
soccer you know I'm gonna do that tell
the check out um season season eight of
no season seven [__] there's been so
many season s of selling sunsets coming
out on November 3rd so is like what day
is that Monday no no wait sorry Friday
that's Friday Friday yeah Frid on Friday
is this coming out before that uh after
just two days after okay fine so if you
haven't already checked out selling
Sunset do that also I am a huge Graham
knows I'm gonna do this I'm a huge US
soccer fan so I just the World Cup is
coming to the United States we're
hosting it for the first time in a
generation in 2026 so do a little bit of
research figure out what's going on
because it's going to be really exciting
you can look into the US Men's National
Team the soccer team and that's who's
representing the United States in the
World Cup it's a phenomenal sport we got
lonel Messi the best player in the world
now playing in the United States so just
open up your mind to soccer because it's
been a lot of fun for me so I just want
to give that little 30 second shout out
Li Messi is not the best but with that
said you guys no I'm kiding I'm k no I
think L Messi is with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching next time
until next
time we're really excited to announce
today's sponsor HubSpot look I could say
from experience that running a business
could often feel like juggling a whole
bunch of things at the same time and one
of the most overlooked aspects that most
people don't even consider is digital
marketing that is exactly where HubSpot
comes in they've recently acquired the
hustle which is a newsletter started
with just one person and is now
skyrocketed to over 3 million followers
hpot in the hustle have teamed up to
bring you a comprehensive guide on
exactly what you need to do to build an
effective newsletter and I say all of
this as somebody who has a newsletter
already with over 40,000 people on it if
you're not doing a newsletter you
absolutely should consider it because
it's so powerful Graham that sounds
really expensive well the good news is
that this is completely free and by
signing up for the newsletter you're not
only gaining access to Super valuable
tips and tricks but you're also becoming
a part of the hustle thriving business
Community it's a place where
entrepreneurs like you can connect and
watch other businesses flourish now you
might be wondering are newsletters even
relevant in this day and age well when
it comes to digital marketing volume is
key and when done right newsletters can
drive thousands of visitors straight to
your website HubSpot provides the tools
expertise and strategies you need to
make your newsletter stand out and again
I'll tell you from firsthand experience
having a newsletter is so important
because the people you reach that sign
up with a newsletter are the ones you
really want to reach out to so don't put
this off don't just think oh I'll do it
later take your business to the next
level with HubSpot so click the link in
the description to check out your free
newsletter building guide again it's
free that's F
re free free thank you so much HubSpot
and now back to the podcast